good morning members good morning
members of the public we're all very
welcome here this morning
um we've got quite a long agenda so I'll
make a direct start I'll ask the officer
to give us the health and safety
information please all listen
thank you chair may I first remind you
of some domestic Arrangements toilets
are situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room following the fire exit
signs and meet on Ipswich Town Football
Club training pitch
please do not re-enter the building
until the build you are told that it's
safe to do so and please switch off all
mobile phones or turn them to silent
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated theorem the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or accept items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being filmed and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for the webcast and and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lost lawfully excluded
does any member of the public wish not
to be filmed
no thank you finally can members and
officers please ensure that you press
the microphone for speaking and turn off
when you're finished and please lean
quite close to the mic members so that
the members at the back of the room can
hear quite clearly thank you
right item number one substitutes and
apologies
uh councilor Mary McCann
councilor McLaren substituting councilor
Norman
councilman goal
yes I have a declaration of
non-pecuniary interest to declare on the
second items oh substituting for John
Hinton my apologies
thank you very much I'll come to the
next bit now uh we're all present
otherwise decorations of Interest I'll
come back to you so
councilor mcgow
yes I'm sorry I have a declaration of a
non-non pecunery interest as in being
the member for Stutton Ward on the
previous Council and I spoke on the
original Stutton application in 2018.
councilor Parker
chair item three DC 190 triple four five
eleven and Priory I will declare a local
non-pecuniary interest and so far as I
have business arrangements with the
applicants agent thank you thank you
very much they're all noted and uh this
list of the council you're happy
thank you
we'll move on to item number three to
confirm the minutes the meeting held on
the 18th of December
you've all seen copies and head copies
of these
can I I'll take you through the pages
page one
page two
stop me if there's anything page three
page four
page five
Page Six
and seven
page eight
million
page 10.
page 11.
are the old happy
and I have a cancer husband's proposed
it in councilor Busby's sector all those
in favor please show
actually members
sign with us later
oh sorry it wasn't real energy wasn't
present but fine thank you
[Applause]
all right item four
to receive any notifications for
petitions
Rob none received here all right we'll
move on to item five which is site
inspections I believe we have two being
called by officers uh would you like to
take us through those first
thank you
um councilor zank Norman has requested
that this has a site visit a committee
site inspection has been carried out
previously however following the local
election not all members of the planning
committee have had the opportunity to
see the site in person
the site is a land east of bramford Road
sprawton and the application is for pool
planning permission for 49 dwellings
the application site is to the north of
the village of sprouton uh Brantford to
the South as it get to the oh sorry
the application site is to the north of
the village of sprouton bramford is
north of that site or shown off the map
uh part of the site is in the flood zone
you can see the flood zones by uh the
blue colored on the screen
there are a number of listed buildings
around the site they're shown in red
the whole of the site is within the
gipping valley special landscape area
this is the proposed layout with one
vehicular access point onto the b113
three pedestrian links are proposed
their Aruba Hood cables in the northern
sector of the site which is also within
the flood zone no development is
proposed in this area a green space is
proposed to the South Eastern area of
the site to give space between the sport
and Hall and the tithe Barn which are
both listed buildings
just moving on quickly to photographs
this is taken looking South towards
Broughton with the access point to the
development on the left hand side
this is looking into the site from the
b113 with sporton Hall and the tithe
barn and church clearly seen to the back
of the site there
uh this is taken within the site under
the overhead cables looking South
towards lower Street in sprouton
this is within the site looking South
with the properties that face onto the
b113
looking Southeast towards a listed
built-in buildings Sport and Hall the
tide barn and the church
this is taken from the south of the site
looking East towards tithe barn and
scrotum Hall this is where the open
space would be
this is taken from the middle of the
site looking South to the properties in
lower Street
this is taken from the Southeastern
corner of the site with the properties
of lower Street and facing onto the B 11
13.
looking South at the existing properties
in lower Street
and again
this is taken from the south looking
North with Spartan Hall on the right
hand side
this is taken from the car parking area
for the tide farm and the community shop
the b113 looking north towards bramford
[Applause]
and that is the site layout
it's a it it is expected that this uh
item will come to the next committee on
26th of February if members were minded
to do the site visit you would need to
park in Church Lane and the meeting
point would be the community shop in
tide Barn
thank you
well members have you seen enough of the
photographs do you feel it's necessary
to have a site inspection or would we be
happy for these photographs and others
that will be presented at the full
meeting uh councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman um well as is
Orion said by the officer we have
actually had a site visit here but
I'm obviously of an opinion that there
are members now that weren't on this
particular last site visit although I am
happy with the photograph Etc I would
imagine that the newer members would
probably pay up to to have a visit on
this
or counselor Barrett is another member
so we'll see we'll have views are that's
right um thank you um yes I haven't been
on a site visit at this location but
we've probably got more photographs from
that short presentation than we often do
have and I'm I'm quite satisfied that
that allows me um to really understand
the site and the location and the the
buildings surrounding it so I'm happy
not to have a site visit
thank you
um right
any other views that's been um suggested
that we don't have a site inspection by
councilor Barrett uh do I have a sector
for that
well I was saying to it so that we can
move on right we'll put it to the phone
all those in favor of the site
inspection please not to have a site
inspection please show
two so that's all those in favor for the
site inspection
that's carried so I have a site
inspection on the 26th okay
you'll get the details in the normal
particular way right take us to the next
one please
thank you
um Stephen shroud the case officer has
requested that a site inspection is
carried out for this proposal some
members have already been to the site
when this was presented by Catherine
Altman on the 22nd of November 2017.
there have been a change of members on
the committee since that time and
Stephen believes it would be prudent for
all members to see the context of the
site to make sure that an informed
decision is reached in case of a legal
challenge
the application is for to the rear of
one to six the street Kersey for seven
dwellings
the site is within the conservation area
of Kersey and also within a special
landscape area as you can see most of
the properties on the street are listed
buildings numbers one to six a grade two
star listed shown in red the green
buildings show a grade one listed
properties which there are some quite
close to the site and the yellow uh
properties are grade 2 listed the built
up area boundary is shown by the Orange
Line roughly half of the site is outside
of the built up area boundary
this is an aerial photograph of the site
and this is the proposed layout
these properties towards the rear are
actually outside of the built up area
boundary and there's four there the
other three are just within the built up
area boundary
this just shows a bit of context as as
to where the listed building is that's
the host dwelling
and then these buildings are the three
that are within the built up area
boundary and these four are outside
just some photographs of Kersey this is
from the top of the hill looking down
the site is on the right hand side
the cork Public House is next door to
the site and is this white timber frame
building here
uh this photo on the left shows the
sudden access between the cork Public
House and the Cottages
the photo on the right shows the access
to the north
this shows the cork Public House at the
exit in the access point to their car
parking area to the rear of the pub
and the other pictures show the southern
access point into the site
this shows The Wider access point to the
site to the north
um
these show the rear of the grade 2
listed dwellings
there is a more modern house built next
door which is this large dwelling here
which is just inside the built up area
boundary and is in roughly in line with
the three dwellings that are proposed to
the front of the site
more photographs looking around the site
and these are some photographs of the
historic core of Kersey
this is taken uh and chose the water
splash at the bottom of the hill in the
street and you can just see the cork
Public House here so the site is
elevated from the lowest point in the
village
this is taken from the church which is
the highest point
um looking across
this dwelling here
is the modern dwelling that is adjacent
to the site so the houses would be built
along here and then push further back
okay it shows the openness of the
countryside and the quite linear
building line of cozy
thank you
thank you thank you very much our
members have seen that presentation are
you happy that you've seen enough just
with the photographs or would you like a
site inspection counselor Busby
yeah I've been on this the site visit
before but it is a complicated site and
I think it's essential that everybody
sees it and isn't it the Bell but Kersey
uh councilor Osborne
yeah thank you Mr chairman yeah once
again I have been on this site visit I'm
thorough agreement with Stephen Stroud
um it should be looked at from a
position as Council Busby has said it's
a complicated issue and particularly
accesses so memory is not what it used
to be with me so I'd like to have
another look
thank you I'll take that as a proposal
from councilor buzzman seconded by
councilor Osborne that we all go along
and have a site inspection all those in
favor please show
that's carried thank you very much
uh is there any site inspections that
you wish to call for
no
thank you
we'll move on we've come to
um
item six plan and application and that
is for artists
all got copies of that in front of you
[Applause]
members uh just before we start on this
I wish to read a statement
it is important to acknowledge for the
record that a number of us had
previously heard this plan an
application a committee several others
more than once
this application has been passed back to
the planning committee to redetermine
following a judicial review of the
council's decision which itself followed
an earlier re-hairing after previous
judicial reviews
with this in mind I believe it is
important to State then as now I
approached this application with an open
mind
I do so recognizing that any plan and
application is essential for us to have
regard to the policies and the material
considerations as they stand at the time
we make a decision
as officers report describes the
planning considerations have changed
over the time this application has been
with us and I will partake in these into
account in my own deliberation
I trust that other members in a similar
position to me will take the same
approach and if any doubt seek legal
advice and we will approach this with an
open mind
thank you uh councilor plum
number one thank you chair I agree and
I'll say no more thank you councilor
Osborne
thank you Mr chairman yes I concur with
exactly what you said there I always
love trying to look at things with an
open mind and it won't be any different
now
thank you counselor
sorry yes I'm the same for me open mind
thank you thank you councilor Busby
and for me too chair thanks thank you
very much councilor Parker
reach out I could care with everything
that's being said I agree thank you very
much I think oh councilor just to state
that not not that I don't have an open
mind but I haven't previously sat on
this application therefore it's
irrelevant you you preempt me that is
exactly what I was going to say because
I hadn't done this film before the other
members are all new and this is their
first time of hearing it so they don't
need to um Echo those thoughts but
they'll have open minds as well thank
you
we'll now proceed and go to the officer
thank you so this is an application for
a full planning permission for six
single story dwellings with Associated
outbuildings improvements to the
existing vehicular access and Highway
improvements
um since the previous decision
well at the previous decision the the
council did have a five-year land Supply
it then lost it but as you were aware it
now has the five-year land Supply as
well the only other change since the
previous decision is that the joint
local plan has now got to Reg 18 stage
but as stated in the report it still has
limited weight
so the key planning issues are as set
out there those are the policies the key
issues are the effect of the development
on the special landscape area and the
character of hartis village and whether
the site location and particularly The
Pedestrian connectivity would constitute
sustainable development
so this is the site you can see the site
in red
here
this is the paddocks so the host
dwelling and then this is the remainder
of the land that would remain
undeveloped under this application
um this is green View and I'll just
point out on here these are the steps
down from Greenview that are mentioned
in your report
yeah and this shows the aerial
view of the site so you can see that it
is within a more rural setting so this
is the paddocks this is the garden of
the paddocks and then this is the the
the countryside you'll see on the other
side on the southern side is a bit more
built up
um this is the green with the listed
buildings that you'll see in a minute
right this shows the constraints so the
site is within the conservation area of
artist which you can see it goes out
into the open Countryside here it's also
within the concept of air Conservation
Area
um sorry the special landscape area
which is wider
um there are a number of listed
buildings these are along the green here
and then there's some more spread out
through the Village
um and then
the built-up area boundary is located
here
um so the site is outside of the built
up area boundary which sort of takes
into the uh part of is the division
between the house and the garden of the
paddocks
this shows the the site layout so this
was an amended design following comments
from highways and the Heritage officer
is designed to appear as a collection of
rural or agricultural buildings and so
these are the six dwellings and they're
all sort of connected by either garages
or boundary walls
all the dwellings are sort of two three
bedroom depending on how you use the
layout because they're all bungalows
and you'll note on here that this this
green Gap here which I'll show you on
the other
um draw a picture and the new access in
this location and then this would be the
pedestrian access so it was just a
little bit further out and joining the
access from the paddocks
uh this is a further drawing
um this just gives you an idea of sort
of the age of the development in the in
the conservation area so this is all the
historic listed buildings as noted in
the report this is the character of
heart assist generally have one plot
deep buildings with the countryside
Beyond
um in this area that's slightly
different this is the paddocks which is
a 20th century building and this is
green view which are 1960s development
um and then you'll note this is the
proposed development in this location at
the bottom here this just gives you an
idea of what the development would look
like from North Shore Road so this would
be the first two dwellings
at the entrance
okay so there's some site sections so
this is a to B so this is looking across
the uh sorry a to a is looking across
the site from this direction
um so with the the houses from Greenview
on this end and then this is B2B which
is looking the the other way so this is
sort of this is the house that's from
Green View and this is the
countryside and then this is C to C
which is along here
gives you an idea of the development and
you can also see that it's slightly
stepped so there are a change in
Heights in the in the site
this is just some images of what it
would be proposed to look like so they
are they are sort of modern buildings
with an agricultural type character with
modern materials
again this is some further pictures of
further
drawing showing this type of development
and these are the dwellings themselves
so as you can see they're all all plots
they're all too bad but they've got this
sort of carers hobby room which could be
used as a third single bedroom so
they're all two free bedrooms
again this is plot two
um all got a similar
well they're all slightly different but
they've all got similar accommodation
Within
plot free with that's got a two bag
garage
plot four again with a two Bay garage
that's plot five
and plot six
uh so this comes to some photographs of
the site so this is looking down from
the site so this is from the paddocks
the sort of The Wider Paddock so the
site sort of goes along here and you can
see sort of heart test um village in the
background so as you can see this is
quite a rural site this is the paddocks
on the corner here and then this is one
of the dwellings at Greenview
again this is looking from low Shore
Road into the
um into the site this is the garden of
green view just further on and you can
see it's quite wooded at the back with
the with the sort of the dwellings on
the green further along
this is looking much further out so
getting to the junction with North Shore
Road
um so this is a half test in the
background and the site is sort of
tucked in behind there
again this is looking from North Shore
Road another wider view you can just see
the stable which is sort of on the
corner of the site
this is North Shore Road so
um as discussed in the report there are
some concerns about pedestrians walking
from the site along North Shore Road
because of the narrowness gives you an
indication of the type so this is
looking up towards the site so this is
where you'd have to to walk along
uh that's paddocks out with its garden
and then the site is beyond there
uh this is from the green so you can see
the site you can just see that horse
which was in the other photograph so you
can see the site just beyond so it sort
of peeks through
and then this is just to show you the
steps up that were discussed in the
report these are for green view so they
have less of a walk along the narrow
road potentially than the occupiers of
this development
and the recommendation asset is set up
in your report to refuse
um based on impact on the uh
um SLA and the Hearth character of heart
test and also the lack of sustainable
development in particular due to the the
fact that pedestrians would need to walk
along that narrow road thank you thank
you very much for that
um members we have the parish council
representative John Gill
so if you'd like to come forward you
have three minutes in which to address
the committee perhaps should remain
seated or standard as you wish and I'll
see if there's any questions for you at
the end of it thank you very much
Mr chairman thank you
my name is John Gill I live on North
Shore Road hartest
I've been asked on behalf of heartist
Parish Council
to present members with its views on
this application which is to be
determined today
the parish council opposes the granting
of this application for the following
reasons one
if this proposed development were to be
permitted
it would have a major adverse visual
impact on the historic and natural
environment of the locality
not only is this site within artists con
Conservation Area and in the vicinity of
listed buildings and amenities
but it is also within a special
landscape area
the site is in a prominent position
being one meter higher than the adjacent
local Road
and this together with the height of the
proposed dwellings would have a
substantial adverse impact on the
setting and on the historic and natural
environment of the locality
two
consultations with residents which took
place during the emerging neighborhood
plan process
have clearly demonstrated the importance
to them of maintaining the existing
character of heartist and its
surrounding natural environment
three
the site currently provides a visually
important Gap
between distinct settlements within the
village
forming part of a key View From The
Village Green
and from the corner at the top of the
Lord Shore Road looking down its length
to the padux meadow
this view would be totally destroyed if
the proposed development were to be to
be were to be permitted
4. North Shore Road is considered too
narrow to support the volume of traffic
likely to be generated
by such a development
it is single track for almost all of its
length
furthermore any highways Works proposed
simply to achieve the width necessary
support the development
particularly at and near the junction
with simpling Road the bottom of
hardhurst Hill
would have a highly destructive effect
on the character of the area
the lower part of lortel road is
currently subject to regular flooding
and there is a very real danger that
this would be exacerbated by The
increased discharge of surface water
resulting from the proposed estate
for these reasons
hardest Parish Council vigorously
objects to this application
and believes that it should be rejected
today
thank you
thank you very much sir I want to save
us any questions for you members any
questions to the speaker
no oh councilor Parker
thank you good morning sorry
yes
not within my my remit if you like
if you're at me just to take legal
advice on that point it's the first time
it's been challenged and a fair enough
I'll find out for you because I don't
know the answer
excuse me I'll ask the legal if I was
the present sorry Sheridan I'm
struggling with a slight cold still if
if the gentleman doesn't feel
comfortable answering questions that's a
matter for him but I I might suggest if
the questions from Members might be
purely factual rather than requiring
opinion and he might be able to assist
the committee with if he's sure what the
factual answer is if you don't mind if
that I mean can we see what the
questions are and if you really don't
particularly ought to answer them fair
enough but
um if it's alright with you I'll allow
the question to be asked did you feel
you can't answer it just nod your head
no and I'll move on I'm not going to put
you on the spot that's not the intention
at all okay are you happy with that
wonderful uh councilor Parker bear that
in mind what you've just heard
yeah indeed chair and on that basis if
if I can't get a qualified answer
um then I'm inclined not to um I'll I'll
withdraw the opportunity to ask the
question
um so but it does beg the question if if
the information therefore is qualified
but anyway
um I'll withdraw my don't complicate the
issue uh perhaps you can put it to an
after survey my pay to help you
um councilor Barrett you let your hand
up there and in mind what's just been so
thank you
thank you ask the question you you may
be able to answer it okay
um could I ask do you know of any site
in the village that uh the parish has
identified as suitable for development
I don't know
thank you that's clear
um any other questions members
no thank you very much for accommodating
us on that particular Point thank you
when you're ready in your own time thank
you Mr chairman
uh my name is Douglas chivers I live in
hartest
and I'm a member of the hottest
neighborhood plan working group
I should like to thank the officers for
preparing such a comprehensive report on
the paddock's application
setting out the complex planning history
of this case
and the range of planning issues
involved
I appreciate the fact that the report
refers in some detail
to the relevant sections of the draft
artists neighborhood plan
which we'll be coming forward for
inspection shortly
a fundamental element in the preparation
of the neighborhood plan
was the conducting of a detailed
village-wide consultation process
from the results of this exercise
it is clear that the committee's
approval of this application
would drive a coach and horses through
the expressed wishes of the residents of
artists
approval of this application
in the face of the officers several
itemized recommendations for refusal
would render the preparation of the
neighborhood plan utterly pointless
it would generate a deep cynicism
about the operation of the planning
process in the baber district
thank you thanks very much
um right members cancer Parker question
foreign
thank you Miss Stewarts good morning
actually you are qualified to answer
this question this is going to be the
very question I was going to to ask
previously
sorry champ
um so if you could just plug provide
some clarification Mr chairs so uh
because the report informs us that the
site in question was actually an
allocation
um originally as far as neighborhood
plan working group was concerned but I'm
not too sure whether that has been
withdrawn as an allocated site now or or
not so could you could you tell us
whether it has been withdrawn and and
perhaps why it was allocated in the
first place if the parish was so opposed
to that site as a potential location
thank you
come on
within the um original draft of the
neighborhood plan
the site was not allocated
then the change which has been explained
in the circumstances of the overall
housing need being
in the plan in a satisfactory way
after long debate and not entire meeting
of mines
the
decision was made to include this site
because it was seen to be a possible
insurance against other sites being
identified in artists given the then
situation on the overall housing
allocate housing identification
since then and as we understand it the
council does have a five-year
satisfactory plan there is not need for
this site to be identified which was
opposed in the first instance
so that explains the process through
which there has been in relation to this
site I have to emphasize
that there has never been
creating Enthusiasm ever fought his
sight being where it is and the scale at
which it is with six dwellings because
the neighborhood plan makes it very
clear that no individual site should
have more than four dwellings
reflecting the scale of the village as
it is
thank you I think that's answered that
quite clearly and the officer here was
another agreement so I think you can
take it that's basically all correct
any other questions members uh councilor
Barrett
thank you can I ask my question again
then
um because you might be able to answer
it the um
my previous question was is there any
other site that you have identified that
that within your plan
a very clear decision has been made by
the working group on behalf of the
parish council that no specific sites
will be identified in the neighborhood
plan
thank you that's quite clear as well
thank you any other questions
well
thank you very much
thank you
um now I'm just going to check because
one or two people have been relevant
after we started is there a supporter
present that wishes to speak
on this application
no don't kill is the applicant or agent
present that wishes to speak on this
application
no
uh the county councilor no I know it's
not here
um so we come to the ward members which
is counselor Stephen Plum which is a
vice chairman and a member of the
planning committee and he is elected to
take part in the debate
um so and councilor Holt I haven't heard
from but I assume um counselor
um Plum will may make comments sorry if
I may have my understanding is councilor
Plum intends to take fully take part and
vote so in effect chairman you're
inviting the vice chairman to start the
debate in if you like or or do you
happen to that yeah sorry I didn't mean
to I'm jumping ahead of myself I do
apologize
I'll put it down to your cold
yeah so we're now going to full debate
as the other
um parties are not present uh cancer
plan would you like to start
thank you chair at this particular stage
we're having really great deal to say
other than
um I'm minded at this stage to go with
the officer's recommendations but I'd
quite happily sit and listen to the
debate which means will change my mind
or may not as the case may be
stay a comment thank you very much
members councilor Busby
can I ask um just generally why are we
now having this one back for the third
time what what brought it back to
committee
perhaps if I start this chairman
um if I refer you to page uh nine and
ten officers have endeavored to set out
the context for this
you will see there that the applications
was previously reported
and subject to judicial review on two
previous occasions the application
therefore having been a subject of
successful judicial review falls back to
us as a planning authority to determine
and therefore officers have reviewed the
policies as they presently stand and the
material considerations as they
presently stand and our recommendation
is brought to you on that basis and I
think I can't do better than describe
the detail that's on page 10 in your
report
hopefully that helps councilor Busby
so my understanding is that the reason
it's badly is because of points one and
two of the second judicial review
um failure to give reason to the
decision to Grant planning permission
and failure to determine whether or not
and the extent to which the proposal
complied with the development plan so
are we focusing on those two points have
we got to answer those two points here
is that the reason I'm sure we hope that
I'll get legal advice on that for you
chairman whereas it with the results of
the judicial review is that we're back
to square one so I I would advise that
you you don't
put that aside and simply look at it as
you would any other planning application
there's been a presentation there's been
public speaking offered and um you you
approach it exactly the same way as any
other you have a very detailed officer
office report questions can be asked and
don't don't well when I say put aside
the judicial review it's an unfortunate
history but we haven't a planning
application that needs to be determined
just like many others do in this
committee
uh right uh Candace McCall I followed by
councilor Parker
please don't hold it quite sorry
I apologize Kessler Parker thank you
chair I bought a piece of wood at an
auction doing the same thing
many years ago
um can we uh just just so that we uh our
memories are uh absolutely refreshed and
clear can can we
um uh confirm please chair that the
reasons for
um refusal given by the officer are
precisely the same as those reasons
given in the precise same application
that came forward previously
yes I believe we have changed the
paragraph numbers for the mppf because
that has been updated and all the
paragraph numbers have changed but apart
from that they are substantially the
same
thank you councilman
this time I do have a question chair and
it was to concern I note that the
hardest neighborhood plan
um remains at the same state it was in
in 2018 has it in fact progressed as far
as we know since the original
application was heard
it hasn't it hasn't changed in terms of
its next stage which would be to present
it to the um
Council and if it go through the next
process however I believe that the
neighborhood plan group have been
changing things within it
so at the moment it's still at draft
stage and they may be changing the draft
changing taking policies out of you as
you've seen that they've taken out H4 or
changed it but fundamentally it's not at
the same stage it doesn't mean it sort
of sat there idle they have been working
on it but they haven't got to the next
stage so it's the same weight which is
limited that's my that was my question
in fact the weight is limited and no
more than that is that correct
yes it's currently got limited weight
Okay no Okay
um any other counselor that was just a
comment
uh councilor Osborne followed by
councilor Busby
thank you Mr chairman
um
yes
uh I tend to agree with the office's
recommendation here although I am
saddened that by the position of the
neighborhood plan that they're proposing
that they haven't actually identified
sites within within a heart test
although I absolutely see their points
so I'm afraid I shall have to go with
the officer recommendation
Bank help can slippers
yeah I seem to remember though I found
this very difficult in the past and I'm
finding it equally difficult because I
think it's it is marginal
um looking at the inspectors
requirements that we
give we get failed to give reasons for
the decision to Grant Planning
Commission it's difficult to come up
with anything which is if you like
scientific
apart from I think it's quite a nice
development and I think if that
development was offered to any other
Village they'd probably take it they'd
snap your hands off
um
but there's a butt and there's always a
butt with these things when you're
looking at balance
it affects the view
how significant that is
in my view it's it's not overly
significant yes it does change it and it
will change it forever therefore it does
have a part to play on the other side of
the equation
there's the access the road and the path
that isn't a good road to be coming out
on whether it's by car or by foot
but on the other side of that road
you've got the green View Estate which
is significantly more in my view
damaging than the one that's proposed
here
but it accesses slightly higher up and
in this in a slightly safer position
whereas this one would come out almost
right on the bend
it's I find this one very difficult to
call
and if there's anybody else got the
thing to contribute I'd be willing to
well I've said there's any other
comments thank you or counselor uh
councilor
plum
thank you chair perhaps I can just
clarify for councilor Osborne and for
councilor Busby there is no requirement
in a number of neighborhood plans to
name sites it's merely limited by the
number of developments on that
particular site and I believe that's the
way the hardest neighborhood plan plans
to go very similarly in the way to the
lawshaw one which is now in place if
that helps you
councilor Parker
um just as just as a matter of
clarification chair do we know are there
any proposed allocations in the
forthcoming joint local plan for for
artists
good point uh can you help us on that
you don't have the document I think
has some oh yes Marcus got it we'll get
the answer to that okay uh well I think
we'll we'll get the official answer and
then you might want to comment on that
uh well we're getting the answer that
we'll come back to it I'll see if
there's any other questions
uh cancer
um I would like to say that I concur
with what you're saying is very very
difficult so it's very very difficult
um but on 7.3 looking at the um the
drillings page 26
again I think you you know what they
would do that the solar panels and how
the elements are supported by
environmental health are very very good
so I think we've got to say I think that
is is wonderful it's just a Pity that it
you know it's where it is but I can see
the good and the bad but I think I would
have to go with the planning officer
thank you
yes there are there are no allocations
as far as I can see it within both
hottest Hinterland and and artist cross
green uh Hamlet which is described on
pages 193194 of the draft joint local
plan and even if there were I would
suggest that that is a matter of very
limited weight as described in the
report because this plan too has to be
tested yet
thank you I hope that helps uh cancel
the plan
thank you chair
um just to summarize the recommendation
to Joint local pan for the number of
houses in hardest is 18 over a period
till 2036 I believe
um which is very it's very similar to
that in many other places
um where there is very little
infrastructure to support
such building
um
I would like to make a proposal chair
I've heard nothing to convince me from
the debate that we shouldn't go along
with the officers recommendations and I
therefore propose that we do so
thank you I'll accept that do I have a
seconder all over the place
um councilor is
yes I fully agree I second the motion
and kelp any other comments councilor
Barrett thank you I haven't spoken on
this yet because I'm waiting to hear
what other views were but um
um and I I think you know agree with
councilor Busby that it is it is a very
balanced
scheme there's a lot of Pros for it and
when I read the report I was
um I thought this sounds like a scheme
that's going to be recommended approval
had I not seen the first page of it
initially
um because there's so many
um
so much to recommend it really the the
design of the units I think are good
um and I I think the the harm must be so
negligible
um when I know that there's buildings
further up that lane that are fairly new
sit very high on the lane I think we saw
it on Slide
19 on the left hand side you could see
see that there was a newer property the
houses opposite again there there's a
double the the number that are planned
in this scheme they don't have a
footpath down although they do have the
the steps leading down onto the lane but
I think beyond that there isn't a
footpath directly into the Village
um to to ensure they're you know they're
not walking on the road
um they are the member the um resident
of Carter spoke about the desire to see
um schemes that are uh of a scale you
know four units but these when when you
think about scale you also think about
the number of bedrooms as well and and
the whole size of the the development is
quite contained at six units or within
two or three bedrooms so the scale of
that seems to Accord with their their
their desires quite quite closely
actually
um The Village
Council upon talks about the lack of
infrastructure in the village but there
is a village school there's a bus
service there's a pub there's a village
hall with activities
um there's this good connectivity to to
local local towns both directions
um
so I'm I I think the harm is outweighed
by the benefit because I think in a
village like uh heart test where there
isn't an identified site for some
development
um the the the the needs to be to
accommodate people who as we know want
to move down in size but stay in The
Villages that they live in
um it's it's an attractive scheme
um
and I I I'm leaning towards
um accepting it I also know that
elsewhere in the village there has been
development that's been allowed on the
road out to websted which is um towards
Barrison Edmonds
where uh a house has been been built and
that's got very little football
connection and it's much further outside
of the village so I think that does
um
uh reduce the argument about the The
Village access quite a lot in the
village that's the one that's on ground
designs of course
um
so I'm I'm I'm I would like to you know
as to actually consider approval of it I
know a lot of people are against it but
when you really think about it there is
a lot going for it
well we've had a proposal to refuse and
that's seconded we will take that and do
course if that fails then you'll be able
to come back you'll be the third against
it if that's what you wish to do
um councilman call thank you chair
um looking at this in the round
I can't escape the conclusion that there
have been three officer recommendations
to refuse
there have been two judicial reviews and
I'm beginning to detect a pattern here
and and I believe that it's quite clear
that we should be thinking about that
pattern the office of recommendations
have been made
determination has been made and there
have been two judicial reviews and I
will be voting to follow the officer
recommendation on that account
thank you
any other comments
uh
point out I think that the judicial
review he inspector didn't actually come
out and say that we've made the wrong
decision he came out and made they met
or he or she said that we haven't given
sufficient evidence to support the
decision that we'd made so I don't think
you can necessarily count the
inspector's views as to which way they
would fall it's just saying give us more
evidence
I'm going to ask the officer to comment
chairman if I can contribute and perhaps
uh my colleague Mr Duprey can clarify if
I've got any of this wrong
so the judicial review sets the
situation back to zero in terms
the fact of a judicial review is not a
material consideration uh the material
considerations are set out in the report
and include the development plan the
fact of the judicial review is simply an
analysis if you will of the previous uh
assessment of the committee and the way
it conducted that and the conclusion it
reached it tells you nothing about the
material considerations uh in the first
instance you can see that the case was
conceded on on a failure to give proper
intelligible and adequate reasons and in
essence that is wrapped up into uh the
the two points upon which uh the
judicial review was
made in the second case so uh in in
summary terms the fact of the judicial
review should not be a consideration in
your minds I would suggest uh it merely
indicates uh close public interest and
scrutiny and the veracity of your
decision and indeed if members do not
choose to follow the officer Foundation
there may be something I wish to add
about that but at this point I think
it's best I leave it there
thank you just yeah I agree totally um
it's not at all uncommon for a judicial
review to succeed and the decision to be
then remade and be the same decision but
this time it's lawful I'm not shouldn't
I shouldn't really elaborate more than
that I can if necessary but we'll leave
it there for the moment thank you uh
councilor Parker
thank you yep um I absolutely concur
with um councilor Busby it's in it very
finely balanced
um application I like the application I
like the uh the you know the layout etc
etc but for me paragraph two of the
recommendation is an absolute slam
dunker and it's unless we can come up
with material reasons
um for
um going against that recommendation I I
rather fear uh we have no choice but to
go with the proposal the Council of
plumbers put forward so I'll be sporting
Council plans proposal
thank you Council Jefferson
yeah I concur with um councilor Parker
in another situation I would be looking
to approve these developments there I
like them but for me the problem here is
the location
and I don't think
uh using the Narrow Lane is not ideal
and it would be without in more traffic
use and although there are other
properties built down that lane what's
gone in line in the past doesn't really
mean we should
affect their decision on this
this um application so yeah I I agree
with the officer
thank you councilor the Clown
thank you chair
um I think the design and the um Outlook
that is proposed is wonderful because it
yeah sorry I think it's it's a good
design and it meets the need which we
have in most Villages which is for older
people downsizing or people that need to
go into accommodation that is on one
story however I am so concerned about
the exit and the lane
which in fact is narrower than some
other sites that are being proposed and
so I would go with the officer's
recommendation
thank you
any other comments I think most members
have spoken
uh Sarah is a counselor Owen
yeah I might as well have my little say
yeah um I totally agree that you know
we've got the roads and everything
cannot set out for
um this but the actual the Bungalows are
lovely anything any anywhere else would
be absolutely fantastic but this
situation I think we ought to go with
the officer's recommendation
thank you very much
well members I think everybody's spoken
who wished to speak I've had a proposal
um from cancer plums and seconded by
councilor as to follow the officer's
recommendation which is one of refusal
all those in favor please show
those against
one that is that is carried the
application is refused thank you we'll
move on
members we're now going on to item
number B which is on page 33.
uh Church roads at switch it's happened
um we're having a bit of a change over
at the top here
bright members I think we're all uh in
our places now we'll move on to page 33
um and this is uh
stats on Ipswich and the case officer is
Linda bacon over to you
thank you chairman this is an
application for full planning permission
for the erection of 34 dwellings the
application was originally presented to
committee on the 17th of July 2019 and
was deferred from that meeting
members visited sorry visited the site
two weeks ago at the request of the ward
member before I proceed with the
presentation I have a verbal update to
report two further comments have been
received from local residents and both
have been uploaded to the website the
first letter
encloses their own traffic survey which
was undertaken on the 15th of January
2020 between the hours of eight in the
morning and four in the afternoon and
they have recorded that 188 Vehicles use
Church Road and lower Street and of
those 188 Vehicles 160 cars and they
wish that to be pointed out to planning
committee the second letter relates to
the public open open space plans that
were received yesterday and comment that
these submitted
plans which are included in your table
papers and they comment that it's now
clear that the increase in housing Mass
has had a very negative impact on the
public open space that can be used by
existing in proposed residents and that
the there's a further request that the
four and five bedroom houses should be
removed from the scheme to provide
public open space that's at least
equivalent to the existing proposal so
both of those comments have now been
uploaded to the website
so
start with the presentation
the application site is shown here hash
red at the site visit members view the
site from approximately this point
the site is currently undeveloped open
land
this plan shows the site's location
towards the center of the village the
site is outside of but enclosed by the
built-up area boundary for Stanton
that's shown by the orange brown line
that wraps around the site
the pink circles indicate that the sites
within the archaeological buffer zone
and grade 2 listed buildings are shown
in Orange along lower Street
in this area and there's a grade one
listed wall here
this site this slide shows that the The
Village to the south of Holbrook road is
all within the area of outstanding
natural beauty and that's colored darker
green land to the north of Holbrook road
is all in the special landscape area
the whole of the village is within the
triple SI impact risk Zone and the
village is within 13 kilometers of the
zone of influence for the estuaries
where the recreational disturbance
avoidance and mitigation strategy
otherwise known as Rams applies the site
is close to the primary school
which is here and which can be accessed
via a footpath link from Stutton close
here
this aerial image gives more context to
the site and illustrates the point that
sites enclosed by existing built form
and this aerial image shows the location
of the site in The Wider context of the
village
so as mentioned at the outset this
application was deferred from committee
last year for the reasons shown on the
screen and the subsequent application
and subsequent of the application has
been amended to address these issues the
Amendments will be highlighted in the
following slides
so I turned into the proposed layout
this slide shows that access is off of
Church Road
to the west and there's a central spine
Road as proposed across the site and
either side of that there are areas of
public open space
in addition to the new road pedestrian
access is formed to the South off lower
Street and
to the East Via the track where members
met at the site inspection
the layouts of the dwellings is such
that two-story development is proposed
fronting onto Church Road and as we move
around the site the North Boundary these
are single story dwellings
that's a two-story Terrace of three and
then there are single story dwellings
all along the East Boundary along part
of the South Boundary this is a
two-story detached property located next
to the public open space and proposed
dwellings within the interior of the
site are largely two-story or one and a
half story in height
um
so this is now the
um or highlights the affordable
dwellings they're shown here in um in
red in the the top North West
Northeastern corner of the site
this is the now superseded layout that
members deferred from planning committee
last July the main changes are to the
front elevation of the frontage of the
properties
onto Church Road and that's better shown
on this drawing which shows both the
proposed and the superseded schemes side
by side so the to the south of the
access road previously proposed there
was a block or three built forms there's
now proposed that's been reduced to two
so we've got increased space between
buildings here and to the north the
separation between properties the
property here has been increased
compared to what was previously shown
here
um
so the change in layout is also coupled
with an amended Design This is the
proposed Street Scene showing four
blocks of buildings along the frontage
Church Road providing six dwellings
within so moving from north of the site
to South we have a detached dwelling a
pair of semi-detached properties then
the access road this is a semi-detached
pair the frontage of this one here
actually faces onto the spine Road and
then this is a detached property at the
South End of the site the the roof
Heights have been slightly reduced the
appearance is now more of a cottage
style and this compares to the street
scene that was deferred from committee
last July so this is the Deferred scheme
and it presented five blocks of
buildings
comprising six dwellings and we
so that would have been was a detached a
pair of semi-detached
um
a detached property another detached and
this was a flat over a garage
so this slide illustrates the
differences between the proposed and the
superseded Street Scene
proposed scheme is slightly lower in
Ridge height and there's increased
spacing between the buildings and the
brick walls have been replaced or the
garden brick walls have been replaced
with more hedging
so turning to the design of the frontage
dwellings the front elevations of plots
one and two have been amended to include
render in a color that is approved by
the aom unit
plot 3 is a detached property on the
Frontage and that's brick built
plots
33 and 34 are to the south of the axis
Road and that now includes a mix of
colored render and brick
and then moving towards the rear of the
site along the eastern boundary this is
the design for four of the proposed
semi-detached Bungalows and these are
the affordable bungalows
this is a pair of larger affordable
bungalows
and this is a Terrace of three
affordable homes
um I won't this is the final pair of
affordable homes but I won't show
um all of the designs but we'll just
whiz through some of these slides to
give you more of a flavor of the style
of open market housing that's proposed
by the development
so you will have noted from your report
that the application is submitted as a
revision to a previous scheme also for
34 dwellings that was granted full
planning permission in April 2018.
shown here is the layout plan for the 34
dwellings that have already got full
planning permission the main difference
is that the two Terrace blocks along the
frontage here
have been altered and the car parking is
accommodated here is shown more in Block
in parking courts so we've got sort of
two or three or four parking blocks
proposed previously and the center of
the sites here the public open space is
more curved in form the approved scheme
also includes more smaller units than
now proposed but a table comparing the
approved superseded and proposed schemes
is included on page 46 of your papers
so this image or slide shows the Street
Scenes as approved in 2018 the top image
is the one that fronts onto Church Road
and includes a Terrace of four to the
left side and a Terrace of three to the
right side the other two Street Scenes
are internal and onto the the spine Road
within the site
this overlay shows the approved scheme
in red
over the street scene now proposed so
what's now proposed is that there's less
built form to the right hand side
so you've got a semi-detached pair and a
detached property with space in between
and to the left you've now got a
detached and a semi-detached pair
replace a Terrace of four properties
there's space there now proposed which
was previously part of the the Terrace
four
I'm showing this slide again just to
remind you of the differences between
the design put before you last July
which is the the bottom image and that
currently before you today which is the
top image
um the this side shows the extent of the
public open space that was previously
approved and is as colored green
and the measured areas of land dedicated
to the ponds open space and Landscaping
buffer are given in the top left of the
slide it shows
um
so this
slide now shows the public open space
information for the proposed scheme
we've still got the
the public open space Central to the
site and Landscape buffers and
attenuation ponds shown but overall the
area of public open space has been
reduced by 452 square meters however the
total extent of public open space now
proposed is still double that required
to comply with local plan policy
requirements
turning now to photos the house on the
left is adjacent to the track which is
shown on the right and that's where
members met at the site visits
all these pictures were taken
um before the site was cleared but these
images are views across the site taken
from roughly the point where we stood
when we met on site
and this is an image of the existing
development in Stutton close and
on the left of this slide is the
existing single story development in
Stanton place on on the right we're
looking towards the access track
this is a junction starting close with
lower Street the red brick wall on the
right hand hand image is grade one
listed
this is ancient house in lower Street
and that's opposite the The Wider
pedestrian access routes and the public
open space that's currently being
proposed and ancient hounds is listed
opposite ancient house is this which is
where the pedestrian access will be from
lower Street into the site
this is an image looking East along
Church Road to the proposed access the
existing hedge will be removed and
reinstated to facilitate the access the
access is approximately here
this is a wider view down Church Road
the access
oops is approximately here
and this is a view looking North along
Church Road towards the junction with
Holbrook Road at the top of the the road
so your office's assessment is set out
in your papers the planning balance and
conclusion on page 51 explains that the
site benefits from an existing
permission also for 34 dwellings
the number of open market dwellings and
affordable dwellings Remains the Same as
previously approved The Pedestrian and
vehicular access points also remains
previously approved development along
the frontage has been reduced six units
are now proposed seven have been
approved
the current site layout improves spacing
between existing and proposed dwellings
and favors on plot parking instead of
the parking courts previously approved
and in turn this has led to reduction in
available public open space however the
proposed public open space still exceeds
policy requirements the amended scheme
has been finely tuned to incorporate
changes as requested by the aom unit and
subject to the conditions suggested in
your papers and the completion of a
section 106 agreement the recommendation
is one of approval thank you
thank you
uh right we have members of the public
present
um Sarah Cooper
the parish council right
you have three minutes in which to
address the committee perhaps you'd
remain seated or stand at the end and
I'll service any questions for you thank
you
Sarah Cooper on behalf of the parish
council who have recommended refusal of
this development on the following points
Road Safety the altered layout at the
church Road front of the development
will encourage on-road parking on a road
that's mostly single car width not least
for shopping delivery vans the
significant increase in traffic despite
reports playing it down is a serious
concern putting cyclists and pedestrians
at risk
Junction Safety there's been no impact
assessment on increased traffic to and
from Church Road and Holbrook Road this
is a particularly dangerous area with
oversized coaches and buses using it for
local private schools causing congestion
at the primary school due to a narrowing
in the road coach and bus Wing mirrors
often take up footpath space
bedroom density
the original application proposing only
two and three bedroom houses have been
superseded by proposal now including
eight four bed houses and one five bed
obviously reducing the amount of much
needed two and three bed houses and
taking a small amount of Green Space
there is for nature and Leisure in fact
as seen by the slides the public open
space is reduced by
452 square meters
height of the development the planning
committee have previously refused
permission to build two-story properties
on the Church Road front of the
development instead insisting on single
story or one and a half Chalet style
properties
these are more in keeping with existing
properties on the same road and won't
interfere with the visual and impact of
the road
the council feels that the proposed
double story dwellings taken into Church
Road are not in keeping with the
surrounding area this is a very relevant
as no landscape and visual appraisal has
been submitted
why is this development being treated
differently
lack of trees there's no pledge in a
planning application to plant at least
one tree per Garden this is a missed
opportunity given the climate emergency
and given this land was once an orchard
Renewables the development should come
with a legally enforceable Covenant to
ensure no oil for fired boilers are
fitted by new and subsequent owners
instead opting for Renewables and
properties should also have electric
vehicle charging points
finally a reminder that the perimeter
head should be left to nesting Birds
until the end of nesting season
thank you
thank you very much
um members have you any questions to the
Paris council rep
no
thank you
um we now
we now have two objectors which is share
in the three minutes so they both like
to come forward Sean open and Keith
Karen
Herod sorry
I know it's only one
it's all good yeah
um gentlemen we'll start our timer here
on the three minutes but the officer
will also be doing under mechanic on a
one of these so that we get it correct
uh you have one and a half minutes each
but if you if you stop wherever you stop
the other one can take over but um that
will end after the three minutes okay
thank you very much over to you when
you're ready
good morning I'm here to object to this
application I accept that this site will
be developed but hope that any houses
built here will be sympathetic to their
setting respect the surrounding listed
buildings and meet the needs of local
people
in 2017 stutter Knights viewed the
original application within credulity
34 houses were proposed off one of the
narrowest streets in the village
it also seemed odd to propose urbanizing
the ancient part of the village and to
approve building in a designated aonb
some of the objectives were pacified to
an extent because the application
included a range of small homes and
Bungalows which matched Village needs
and had a large Central landscaped area
which was a major part of the planning
balance leading to approval for the site
the village now feels totally misled
with this new application being so far
removed from the original planning
balance justifying the site's
development
although the number of dwellings is
unaltered Hopkins and Moore's new scheme
proposes removing all of the one bed and
four of the two bed dwellings and
replacing them with nine large four and
five bedroom houses for which they can
prove no local need and which will
dramatically increase the development's
impact on its surroundings
accommodating these big houses requires
cutting the development's central open
space one of the key reasons the
existing permission was acceptable in
the aonb in half
Stutton needs more small houses and
Bungalows not large four and five
bedroom homes and a dense Urban style
development I therefore humbly beg that
the committee refused this application
and allow the existing consent which is
in far better keeping with the Village's
needs and its settings to stand thank
you
okay
um I agree with that being said but if
you are minded to pass this I would like
you to apply three conditions the first
conditions is that in their designer
application Hopkins and more can confirm
the availability of housing to be
provided in accordance with requirements
of policy
cs-19 which says that it should be 35
they are not doing that they're only
providing 32 because there was a mistake
on the original one and they've ported
it across the new one now it's my
opinion that mistakes should be
corrected and this is a new application
and therefore it should be corrected and
so therefore the condition is to comply
with CSX team by either adding one extra
affordable house now in the village
you're probably not aware but they're
desperate for for avoidable houses and
the big the count the parish council
have actually identified a piece of land
where we build six extra ones I mean
these are like gold dust okay the second
condition is a a confusion
I've got no complaints about the height
of the houses but it's where they're
situated and on this one they brought
forward five meters now in in the in the
report uh the officers reported that the
location of the front buildings of the
front Building light remains unchanged I
I don't think it is so I'd lack a
condition to say that the buildings are
set back from the road at least as they
were in the original one and my final
one is actually to put a condition from
the previous one which is condition 21
which ensures that we obey our our
policy cs8 which says that Hedgerow
should not be with planning members and
should be thank you very much you've
gone well over but okay okay we got the
last pint as well
um
right I also if there's any questions
for the perfect perhaps one of you could
turn off
your mics after you've spoken whichever
one decides to speak because otherwise
you'll cancel out the other one
it's not on at the moment because I've
overridden it members
any questions
no
well thank you very much
thank you
we have no supporter present
that wishes to speak
we have the applicant agent which is
Chris Smith
I think you're well aware of the
procedures I won't go through it but if
you've remained seat at the end I'll
serve as any questions thank you you too
have three minutes
thank you chairman members my name's
Chris Smith I'm development planner for
Hopkins and more as you've heard from
the officer following the formal defer
of the proposals back in July last year
development layout has now been amended
in order to try and address the concerns
previously raised by members regarding
the proposed dwelling mix and the visual
relationship with development to the
Church Road Frontage
as you've heard the proposed dwellings
to plots 1 2 21 and 34 have each now
been amended from the previously
proposed four bedroom dwellings to now
proposed two-bedroom dwellings
um with the total floor space of the
dwellings now proposed actually less
than that of the previously permitted
development on the site
all access and car parking Arrangements
otherwise remain as previously proposed
in July along with the remainder of the
layout given that members otherwise seem
broadly comfortable with the previous
layover no respects
we believe that the proposals as now
shown will provide an attractive new
development in a sustainable location
delivering 11 much needed new affordable
homes together with all the requested
Financial contributions towards other
essential infrastructure in summary
therefore we hope you can now concur
with your officer's recommendation and
that you're able to support the
proposals thank you chairman and as
always I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much members do you have
any questions cancel areas
thank you chair and can I just ask will
the um the affordable homes and the ones
will be significantly same so will the
fixtures the fittings where everything
be equal it would not be cheaper and
nasty
the external appearance will be the same
with detailed material schedule with it
as you'll see from the proposals the
external appearance materials detailing
are all exactly the same internally to
fit out if anything will be of a higher
standard it's controlled by the homes
and communities agency we have to comply
with their standards in order to meet
the requirements of the registered
social landlords who will take those
properties so yes
thank you for that reply because I think
it's a fair comment uh cancer as members
are more concerned that nowadays that
the affordables do give as good as they
can possibly give on these sites and
it's encouraging to note that um
developers are taken up more on board so
it's worth noting that kensler McCall
thank you chair
um
Smith
um we heard reference from one of the
objectors about the affordable housing
components and the calculation of it now
I've just done a quick figure myself and
the 11 units is what you propose to meet
the 35 Target now calculating what 12
units would be that would be
um
35.29 so the difference is very marginal
is it possible that the applicant your
developer would consider increasing the
affordable housing component 212 since
with the differences a fraction of a
percent we round down this case rounding
down from 35.29 to 35 the closest we can
get to 35 would you consider that as a
condition
I think chairman what has happened in
the past is that where there is a
perceived shortfall in sort of fractions
and percentages that element is normally
dealt with via a financial contribution
in terms of the perceived element of
shortfall so I would think that would be
the way to go if that was a requirement
of members in this case rather than
seeking to to amend the layout further
thank you
uh uh yes can I follow up on that with
an officer response as to whether that
is possible
uh I think it'd be important to answer
that now
yeah you have several choices here you
could go with what you're being offered
um or you could um resolve in your
resolution to have that extra Financial
contribution or to ask us to go when you
speak to the developer about the extra
unit you have choices
thank you uh councilor Osborne yeah I
think thank you Miss Sharon I'm
interested in the recommendations that
state the uh
it's the recommendations on 52 external
lighting strategy include any
streetlight to be submitted and approved
does that
is that going to be approved by the
council County Council or is that uh
with your with your development
if the street lighting required then it
will have to be designed to Suffolk
County Council highways standards and
requirements
um we are flexible in whether the street
lighting or not some Villages want to
have Street lines some don't if they do
then yes it will be provided to County
Council Highway standards if it's deemed
not to be required then then there won't
be any or there'll be any very sort of
low-level Bollard line
would they adopt your
the highway the main spine Road through
the site is proposed to be adopted and
yes therefore if there was streetlight
required it could be put alongside that
thank you
any other questions
answer the call
just a question Mr Smith if I'm not
mistaken there's been some suggestion
that this is a light sensitive area
being in the aonb that a bat population
is present is that correct
yeah
the site is in the OMB there are some
trees around where bats May well
frequent and therefore yes the the
inference therefore is the darker Skies
approach maybe more more
um desired in this sense and and we
would be happy to go along with that
what plans have been proposed by the
parish council for lighting on the site
I'm not aware directly of what plans the
parish council have I thought there was
reference somewhere in the papers to
Bollard lighting rather than formal
Street lighting low level I could be
wrong however I think he'd already refer
to low-level Bullard Blyton
councilor Osborne yeah thank you Mr
chairman I'm sorry I need you to come
back I'm very interested and and I
haven't heard a
presentation by somebody in ecology with
swift boxes I I would very much like to
see that you will carry that out and is
that part of your position
yes we've undertaken ecological surveys
and as part of that there are
recommendations in there they include
proposals for Swift bricks or boxes
depending on which is the most
appropriate and it's something we've
done on a number of sites previously
good any other comments members
questions
no thank you very much
foreign
members we now move to the ward member
councilor Mary McCarron over to you you
have five minutes in which to address
the committee at the end of it I'll
serve as any questions for you
thank you chairman
um at the outset I would just like to
thank the chairman and the planning
committee for the site inspection two
weeks ago
um I felt that was very helpful I would
also wish to thank all the residents of
Stutton who have supplied me with a lot
of comments
since the deferment of this application
in July 2019 I don't think I've changed
in my view of my concerns for this
development
the designs of the house facing to the
front of the site are two-story
dwellings which are in stark contrast to
the single story dwellings on the same
side of Church Road and the new overall
design is not in keeping with the
village scenario in an area of
outstanding natural beauty
the big increase in the number of
bedrooms on the site from 72 which went
up to 96 and now be has been brought
back to 92 will impact the number of
people accommodated and more importantly
the number of vehicles used in the
development
Church Road already has a problem with
the free flow of traffic versus the
safety of cyclists pedestrians
wheelchair users pushchairs and
unaccontinent children
with the average Village Family using
three cars the limited parking spaces on
this site will push residents cars into
Church Road causing more dangerous and
obstructive parking
the affordable housing which is 11
dwellings within this plan are all in
one area which could seem to be a bit
discriminatory it would have been nice
to have a more integrated development
the drainage pond on the site causes
concern how will it be maintained and
how will small children be protected
from this hazard
Church Road and lower Street have a
history of crumbling water and sewage
pipes recently a tanker spent several
days 24 hours a day pumping out sewage
when the temperamental pumping station
in lower street again failed to function
one family near the site have moved due
to the regular appearance of sewage in
their Garden
anglian mortar have given no reassurance
that this will be addressed in the short
or long term
another possible 92 contributions that
requires no further comment
the entrance to the development does not
meet the minimal minimum visibility
splay of 90 meters required for the
safety of all residents using Church
Road
finally this does not meet the housing
need in Stockton as many long-term
residents are looking to downsize from
their large houses to sit to single
story dwellings or two to three bedroom
houses
I would
respectfully ask chairman that the
planning committee review this planning
application in the light of all the
objections thank you
thank you very much
members
any questions
no
thank you very much then there's no
questions to you you can remain but you
can no longer comment okay thank you
uh rope members it's over to you who'd
like to start
we must remember that this already has
an out has um outline plan no full plan
permission
uh on this site
capable of implementation
so uh councilor Osborne
yeah thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm very
interested in the highways response here
and with comments from uh councilor
um
Mary there
has the
I mean the splays ETC would that that
should have been considered by by the
highways Authority and also they they
give you a no objection for for the
standard conditions so I would just like
to ask the officer what their uh Linda
what the position is with those thank
you
so certainly the county highways have
seen the
the proposed plan see they haven't
raised an objection or a reason for
refusal on the visibility display
um and yes they have given comment about
the increase in number of bedroom spaces
um
which doesn't actually affect their
overall comment their comments are based
on
um the number of bedrooms and the
resulting number of parking spaces are
required to record with that size of
property so we have no objection from
the highway Authority conditions will it
be imposed concerning the visibility
display being
shown as as shown on the drawing
any other questions uh councilor
well not a question just a general
comment as we are we at the stage of
General debate sorry
um yeah I like councilor Osborne I'm
actually somewhat disappointed in the
highways authorities response since one
of the principal reasons having sat on
the committee before on this application
is a substitute
um one of the principal reasons it was
returned referred away back was to have
highways look at this point the very
point of the increase in the number of
bedrooms and therefore the impact
not having been considered from that
increase compared to the previous
position as I see it they're suggesting
they're saying we don't do that
but if we did this is how we might do it
which is I think there's something wrong
with the methodology if I'm modest about
it um but they are suggesting that um a
approximate increase because of the
number of bedrooms equivalent to five
dwellings now I calculate that that's a
30 increase in the number of bedrooms
but only a 17 increase in the number of
car movements now unless Suffolk County
Council highways believe that uh larger
houses will only be occupied by people
with children who never grow up I would
suggest that there are likely to be
rather more cars than that
further I'm still very concerned the
narrowness of Church Lane I've been down
it many a time
um just on a bicycle
and uh if you've got a car coming the
other way your bicycle there isn't room
for your bicycle and a car in terms of
width it is that narrow and I think that
can be seen by the map that was
distributed to uh members within the
papers you compare the with the spine
road on the actual development with the
width of Church Road to the West
and even lower Street to the South they
are considerably narrower than what is
considered to be an adoptable Road
according to Suffolk highways now with
all those things in point I would
suggest that Suffolk Highway's response
is inadequate
um I'm still very disappointed in that I
can see some improvements in the overall
layout but I think that's a primary
concern that I've always held
uh thank you for that I mean the
highways Department uh this planning
committee and previous claim committee
over the years we always think the
highways
Engineers Department uh
have a sort of a law unto themselves
sometimes but they are the experts and
at the end of the day they have looked
at it as the officers said they've had
the comments given to them they have
said that it is okay and acceptable and
that they are applying the conditions
that they've asked for so whilst I can
agree with a lot of your points
we're we're on a heightened to nothing
to go down that road but I'm quite happy
to ask officer to explain it in detail
to you but I think that's going to be
the same
no you're happy so I'll move on
councilor uh Parker I think you were
next
okay cancel the Jefferson
correct in thinking that if we refuse
this application the applicant can go
back to the original
um approval and this and just build that
so yeah okay yes um right he can just
build out what he's already got
permission for
slayers
thank you chair
I'm worried I'm
land contamination I'm hearing what um
councilor said there because according
to page 49 81182 that there's been no
objection
to the scheme will land come
contamination and
um all the flood and water risks so
maybe we could find out a bit more about
that
because for somebody to move
it's quite serious isn't it
can you answer that I mean they've
already got permission to do it and well
yes they have permission to build there
but in addition with this application
the required report so
um we're submitted with the application
so we have had the land contamination
report it's been reviewed by the
Environmental Protection Team and they
raise no objections
um and likewise the county flood and
water team have looked at the submitted
flood risk assessment and are happy with
its content so they don't raise an
objection either so we've had the
required reports they've been checked by
our County colleagues our experts and no
objections are erased on that basis
thank you
any other comments
uh councilor Busby
funny old game is planning really
we gave we refused planning application
for a design that we all like
and we're recommended to approve one
that we don't like
um
I don't know where that takes us quite
frankly
I've just remind you to deal with the
one that's in front of you that helps
well actually I'd prefer to deal with
the one that was approved two years ago
the 72-bedroom unit I I don't think
enough Improvement has been made
but thank you for the plan if all
applications could come with a layout
like that that would be very useful
um
I think they should have stuck with the
72 bets
um I think there was room for
improvement on on the layout
particularly along Church Road
um and I think that that would have then
presented uh
an application which was
approvable is that a word
um
I don't think this moved to 92 bedrooms
is an improvement on that
you know there are things that need to
be done but this hasn't done it
necessarily well enough to justify me to
approve this particular plan I think I
prefer to still work with the old one
thank you
any other comments
uh councilor Barrett thank you um just
really
um following on from
cancer Busby's comment about I I don't
know whether it's really Justified the
increase in the number of four bedroomed
houses
and as the applicant has permission for
what seems to be a more acceptable
scheme
um I'm not sure that and also the the
increase in number of bedrooms I don't
think there's been any consideration of
the extra parking that's that's that
would be needed um I think that would
result in a a crowded
um
uh estate with uh with you know with
them with too much on street parking so
um I I too I'm sort of like counselor
Busby and I'm I'm not so keen on this
members uh I think this came back to us
because of comments that were raised so
I'm just going to get that pointed out
to us yeah thank you just to confirm we
obviously debated this in July last year
and the reasons for
deferral at that time were the need for
the size of Dwayne's proposed as we've
been discussing the size scale layout
and character of the development in
relation to the setting of The Village
the impact of the extra bedrooms from
the previously approved scheme from the
highways perspective and those were the
those were the reasons rather than any
um anything about this displays or
anything else like that but those are
the three reasons it was actually right
thank you so very helpful
um if I could just come back on the
point about the car parking spaces the
currently proposed scheme does meet
County Highway standards the adopted
standards for number of parking car
parking spaces the um the larger
properties where they have a double
garage they've also got two visitors uh
two parking spaces so they've got four
spaces for that property and in addition
six visitor spaces are distributed
across the site
so they've accommodated it right members
we need to move on on this
councilor
chair I'm gonna confess to being
confused by this and that's not
difficult to confuse a silly person
but is the situation here that that this
committee asked
um uh the applicant to go away and
rethink this the applicants come back
and re-thunk it as it were and now the
suggestion from the conversation is
we're not happy with the rethink is that
is that where we're at that seems divert
yep
well
on that basis I I'm not particularly uh
opposed to either this application or
indeed the previous one but this is this
is the one that we're dealing with um so
um I'm going to propose chair that we
accept the officer's recommendation as
set out in the report
thank you do I have a second up
yes I'd second that fully aware of
what's Happening thank you very much
any other new comments members
no
right it's been proposed and seconded
that we accept it
sorry to button there was a discussion
about and I don't know where you arrived
at on this the the commuters sum to top
it up to the 35 members I don't know
whether you wanted to carry that through
on the resolution
right councilor Parker did you want to
add any of that in or stick with what
you've already proposed
I think Sheriff the applicant is
prepared to um to to do that then um
then yes I would like to propose that
Chancellor Ayers
yes fully agree
so it's proposed with that
um extra condition to get the check no
not a position it's a what about the
106. 106 right yep I know it was there
um
so hopefully the applicant will take
that on board it's been proposed and
seconded
against the Busby doesn't that change
the actual
president you know what we're voting on
we're not voting on what has been
proposed in that case we're voting on
something else I'm a bit on the 106.
it's basically they will provide some
money to the commuted some affordable
housing just going to a pot somewhere so
the scheme will stay the same
right members it's been proposed and
seconded with that additional pint all
those in favor please show
let's see
two four five I'm sorry
I'm sorry cancel from there sorry six
six
those against
four
that is carried thank you very much that
is approved
members there's a very uh short five
minute Comfort break because we just
need to move around Forest speakers in a
wheelchair
don't moan at me later for the length of
the meetings we did say to get back here
on time anyway we'll continue
we're
on
on item C which is on page 57 Platinum
and that's uh
Samantha over to you
thank you
um you may notice that I do have members
from the enforcement team and the
Heritage team here to answer any
questions that you may have about the
application today
perhaps you could do that after my
presentation
um
just to draw your attention to the table
papers there are a few items that we've
included in there one is a statement
from the enforcement officer as you may
recall when we carried out the site
visit
a fence had been erected along the
public footpath that has been deemed
permitted development
um there is another piece of fencing
further inside the house inside the
garden closer to the dwelling that is
still under investigation at the moment
also included in the table papers are a
statement from the planning agent and
also something from the parish council
to address any other concerns that may
have been raised during the application
process
this application is for Lebanon Priory
in Water Street Lebanon members carried
out a site inspection on the 29th of
January following this item being
presented at committee on the 18th of
December
the application seeks full planning
permission for the erection of an
eco-dwelling within the grounds of a
grade one listed building Lebanon Priory
and within the conservation area of
Lebanon the application is being heard
at committee because of the level of
interest and proposal 15 residents have
objected to the scheme lebanum Society
Suffolk preservation trust the parish
council historic England and the
council's Heritage team have all raised
objections to this application
there have been 37 letters of support
Lebanon Priory is located on Water
Street which forms part of the medieval
Corps of Lebanon the application sites
sits to the south of water stream
the grounds of Lebanon Priory form an
l-shape
the application side is in the
Southeastern Eastern corner of the
grounds just here
it is not considered to be direct
cartilage of The Priory which is why the
fencing is considered to be permitted
development
but it is clearly associated with The
Priory
the red line shows the application site
the Blue Line shows the extent of the
land associated with The Priory
Water Street is this street here we have
the High Street which runs south to
North here
Bay Street is along this section here
the site is contained within the
historic core of Lebanon with Open
Fields to the South which are within a
special landscape area the site is
within the conservation area with many
listed buildings running along Water
Street including the grade one list of
properties of Lebanon Priory and devere
house
the built-up area boundary is this brown
color here
and the site is outside of the built up
area boundary
public footpath runs along the rear of
the garden here
and goes from brentily road which is
here up to Bears Lane
this is an aerial photograph showing the
context of the site to the village and
The Wider landscape
the site is outside of the built-up area
boundary but is considered to be well
located to access facilities within the
village itself
this plan shows the proposed layout of
the site the access is from Water Street
just here
and it runs through the car parking area
for Priory Farm court and then through
the garden of The Priory the dwelling
would be cited in the Southeastern
corner of this Garden
the proposed eco-dwelling would be
single story and partially underground
with a green roof
to help minimize visual impact on its
surroundings two applications for
similar dwellings have been refused on
site previously in 2009 and 2010.
the 2010 refusal was then taken to
appeal and dismissed these were also
within the late papers that you were
given this morning
they were dismissed on Heritage grounds
[Music]
the application is a resubmission of a
previous application from last year
which was withdrawn because of
objections on Heritage grounds
this is the floor plan showing the
dwelling and the garage with parking
area a large glaze panel is to the front
making the most of solar gain
this shows the position of the dwelling
in the garden and the boundary
uh when we were carried out the side
visit you will have noticed the Bears
Lane development of 25 dwellings that is
currently under construction
this is the site area is defined by this
red line here our application site is up
here
[Applause]
uh the parish council have objected to
this scheme because the the proposal's
impact on the green Fringe Of The
Village
and the relationship of The Priory to
and its link to the countryside this
area of Lebanon has been defined as high
high landscape sensitivity uh within the
character assessment which forms part of
the adopted neighborhood plan therefore
development of this site is contrary to
the neighborhood plan
as you can see the Bayes Lane
development leaves a wide swathe of open
space
between the main village and the
built-up area boundary and the
development itself
um
the Asian has provided some helpful cgis
to try and help you visualize how the
building might look this is taken from
the south with the put path running
along here and the dwelling in this part
here
this one is showing you how it may look
from inside the site itself
foreign
from inside the site
this is showing how the driveway to
access the dwelling would be cut into
the garden itself
moving on to some photographs this is
The Priory from Water Street
the access point
this is a Priory Farm Court
these photographs were taken when leaves
were in full leap the trees were in full
Leaf however you have seen the site
without the leaves it is heavily wooded
with mature trees and hedging around
uh you can just see the pins here
with the footpath on the other side of
that fence
just some more photographs just to give
you some context of the site itself and
it's open green area
this building here is the one that we
saw on site that is to be demolished and
their dwelling will go quite close to
where that is located
foreign
last week actually at the top of the
Bears Lane foot path looking down this
is one of the important viewpoints that
have been addressed or have been spoken
about by the parish council and also by
our heritage team
walking down the footpath the site is on
the left hand side you can see how open
and green the area is and actually quite
tranquil when you're walking down there
nice picture of my dog
this is looking South across the Open
Fields
this is looking back from Brent TV road
back up towards the village you can just
see the new houses that have been
developed here
the site is further up here
um
this is also one of the important
viewpoints that have been mentioned by
the parish council
and just a bit further back down towards
brinty the road looking back up towards
Bears Lane
um we have included some historic Maps
Ordnance survey Maps this one is from
um our site that we're looking at today
is just here
and as we flick through the next couple
of slides you'll see that this has
remained a really undeveloped part of
Lebanon
again with the site just here
and choose the footpath this one was in
1904.
and this is the aerial photograph that
has been recently taken so all of this
green space has remained undeveloped
and I have included the emerging
local plan
math which shows what
the council is thinking in terms of
their new built up area boundaries
the site that you're looking at at the
moment is here which Still Remains quite
a long way outside of the built up area
boundary should the plan go forward
okay the objections to this proposal are
not visual
the design of the dwelling the scale
um you know that's accepted that most of
it will be hidden from viewpoints that
are public
um the roof will be covered with a green
roof and it does re result in very
little into visibility with the listed
buildings in Water Street
the planning inspector in 2010 concluded
that a dwelling in this location would
not comply with local plan policy cno8
which is at our Conservation Area policy
because of its intrusion into
undeveloped open land marking the
fringes of the conservation area and
departure from the prevailing pattern of
development for these reasons the
character of the conservation area would
neither preserve nor enhance
since 2010 local policy is unchanged but
with the introduction of the mppf and
the absorption of the neighborhood plan
Heritage assets are given even more
importance
historic England have raised an
objection to this scheme
it's actually quite rare for them to
raise an actual objection they often
make recommendations on how
schemes can be developed to make them
more acceptable that is not the case
with this application
what historic England have actually said
is these undeveloped green spaces which
have always been ancillary Garden field
and paddocks to the historic houses and
form the settlements interface with
these wider rural setting make a
positive contribution to the historic
significance of the Conservation Area
as a whole
as well as the wider setting to The
Priory and other listed buildings to
develop part of this area for housing
would permanently
change this historic land use and the
pattern of development with a harmful
impact on the historic significance of
the site itself and setting of any
listed buildings which can be
experienced from it or in views
containing it
in this particular case it would be from
the public put parts
the current the current application
again proposes proposes building on the
site and the harm resulting by
detracting from the contribution to the
open green spaces makes
partly burying the house does not remove
this simple fact of development which is
in itself harmful the Heritage team have
identified less than substantial harm to
Heritage assets and therefore as
required by the mppf public benefits
should be weighed against that harm
public benefits are limited when one
dwelling is proposed
really that it's just the result of some
jobs during the construction phase and
adding one dwelling to the housing stock
um this is not considered to outweigh
the harm to the conservation area and
the setting of the listed buildings
this question is more about principle of
development in those open green areas it
is contrary to our policies to the mppf
to the Lebanon local plan and therefore
it is recommended for refusal as set out
in your documents thank you
thank you very much for that
right we have public speakers Parish
Council Mr Shepard
when you're ready
thank you chairman
attorney Shepherd from Lebanon Parish
Council
the parish council recommends refusal of
application
and they'll go through the lines for
that we did not support the previous
application for this site
many on the grounds including harm to
the settings of The Priory
its location of land forming the green
Fringe to the Village
and its relationship to The Priory and
to the um
listed buildings on Water Street
the reduced size of the proposed
application this time although is less
intrusive than the original application
that has to be slightly moved we still
feel the existing objections still apply
nfpp says overriding objectives as a
protection enhancement of the historic
environment
our first grounds
our landscape character assessment
clearly identifies this area as
landscape High sensitivity
and this is referred to in the
neighborhood plan and there are diagrams
showing the views into and out of this
area and showing this era of sensitivity
now they've had development policy plan
H1 that schemes adjacent to the built up
area boundary can be clearly
demonstrated well related to existing
pattern of development in lavenum
the scale and character of The Proposal
reject respects the landscape landscape
features streetscape
townscape Heritage assets and important
spaces and historic views into and out
of the village
and we have used at the basis of our
objection
baber local plan policy cs-15
basically contains the same objectives
as Lebanon neighborhood plan policy H1
in addition the emerging joint local
plan which has completed its regulation
18 consultation
contains the concept of built-up area
boundaries
in this case the proposal is outside the
proposed boundary
development outside the boundary she
could set a precedent or could set a
precedent for any similar developments
outside any built up boundary across the
district and further frustrate the
progress of a direct local plan
in view of the above there are no
grounds for the parish council to change
its view
on the development of the proposed
dwelling in this application
moreover paragraph 12 of the national
planning policy framework
gives the gracious way to existing
policy documents and at the Pinnacle of
these is labor Levin and neighborhood
plan
under nfppf any decision departs from
this may only be made in light of
material considerations
an approval five-year housing Supply
policy in this area may be very as valid
any decision to allow the application
would be a major department from policy
yeah The Proposal before you is in
conflict with national planning policy
framework the emerging enjoyment thank
you Mr Shepard your time is up I'll
service any questions for you oh thank
you very much members
uh Council areas
um I was wondering
um the bear Lane development or um was
that outside the um permitted area
it is but they're quite happy
with I you know I'm just wondering
because that's higher on the hill and I
visited it recently designed there was a
lot of consideration given so given to
its impact on The View and that's why
when you look to those plans it's just
very much
governed by that fencing and with the
view left open across the lower part of
the
that site and field into the Brett
Valley
questions councilor Park
thank you Mr Shepard I'm looking at your
neighborhood plan document here policy
H1 seems to suggest in the plan that
there are circumstances under which
development could be accepted and you
did make reference to it actually in the
notes but just for clarification So the
plan here um there's three bullet points
um and I think they're absolutely
critical to this application if you
don't mind me saying share so is it your
contention then as uh lavender Parish
Council that this proposal meets none of
these criteria could you clarify
oh sorry our view is it doesn't meet the
the Criterion in total sense and
therefore we would contend it is in
it it doesn't comply with housing given
H1
that's thankful
any other questions
that cancer Busby
all right apart from within the actual
sites of a priority where could you
possibly see this this building
we have no view on where this building
could be located this is the second
application
for development here and this building
has been moved
from the previous application but in our
we have no view our view is that anybody
in this area is in contravention of
the protection of the historic
environment
with great respect Mr Shepard the
question was where would you feel it and
I don't think you actually answered it
and ask the question very well okay
if you were
anywhere in Lebanon apart from the
application site could you see this
building
the parish council would support good
Eco building within the village
providing the societies
in the right location
generally so that we have no objections
to an Eco building you have no
objections to Modern design
in this case it is purely about the
location of the building
thank you I don't think you've got the
answer that you wanted it was yes or no
I think but anyway you've done any other
questions to the applicant
but
thank you very much Mr Shepard
um we have an objector Anthony ramsetter
user you're already there so that's
that's fine and carry out when you're
ready thank you very much Karen thank
you community members I'm very grateful
to be here I'm here to oppose this
application I'm speaking as a resident
of lavender I'm speaking as the owner of
devere house the grade one listed
property but joining laven and Priory
and this site
um
my objections are very similar to those
you've heard rather proposals today and
it's been very helpful for me to hear
those other proposals and their
rejection I'm objecting on the grounds
of design location and the precedent to
be saved
in terms of the design this is a
building that whilst well designed for
somewhere
is not sympathetically designed for the
location proposed it doesn't fit in with
the peaked roof pegtiles and clay tile
roofs that are seen four distance
uninterrupted by a single solar panel or
flat roof from the Viewpoint of the site
that view does not include anything like
this
there are other examples of Eco
dwellings being built in the village but
not in this location
in terms of then its location it has
been mentioned already it's in a
conserved area it's in a landscape
Scenic area
it abuts to a property that is the
second most photographed dwelling house
in the country
one that appears in films is a film
actor in the Harry Potter films no less
both sides of the house and the view
from this learning down towards the
village includes what was the frontages
of the manor The Priory and devere house
they're ancient front doors were all
seen from this aspect
and in the maps and photographs of this
site we see it referred to as open
Gardens as grasslands as commonland at
one point it was shared by all of the
houses on Water Street as their Gardens
it has been open to the public as an
Open Garden
so this is a site that is very much seen
as grasslands and part of the landscape
historic views into our village
and so that whilst we welcome the design
and the tremendous effort has gone into
the design we believe that this location
is the wrong place for this design and
that it would substantially disturb the
heritage of our village if it were built
on this site instead of Preston there
would be extraordinary dangerous because
it cuts across a neighborhood plan that
has been agreed that has been consulted
with the village and that one
development should so cut across such a
plan damages the local democracy
so I therefore ask you to reject this
proposal on free grounds
the design is not appropriate to the
site the location because it's only
reserved sorry a conserved area and
thirdly the president that will be set
which inspector over what's considered
to be a very dangerous precedent indeed
that this would permit further
backfilling of the gardens along Water
Street behind the grade one and grade 2
Heritage listed buildings along that
street
thank you very much for your time thank
you very much members do you have any
questions to the last speaker
no
thank you thank you very much
we'll move on now we have a supporter
and I've already apologized to the young
man because there's no way I'm going to
be able to pronounce his name so I'm
going to ask him to come forward and
perhaps you'd like to introduce yourself
and
um and then we'll start the three
minutes after that
thank you
and visual understand why I couldn't
pronounce the name
hello my name is Son ramchelawan and I'm
studying architecture at Loughborough
University
my email support for this proposing go
out as one of 50 other written
expressions of public support shown on
the planning portal
when I'm not a uni I live in Lebanon
with my family my home is in Meadow
close which joins the Bears Lane
development of 25 properties area
completion by developer modern homes
the Bears Lane developer is in itself
outside the billup area boundary and
shares a boundary at 11 and Priory
the planet consent for the Baseline
development was granted by this
Committee in December 2017 that can send
evidences your flexibility to approve
development proposals outside and are
joining a built-up area boundary in
accordance with your planning policy
cs11
I regularly use a footpath border in the
lavender prior in the Bears Lane
Development I've carefully studied a
computer-generated images of the
proposed ego house in my opinion there's
this squizzly design scheme which if
approved and constructed will not be
invisible from the footpath
or any other viewing corridors
more importantly its design enables it
to exist in harmony with a very high
level of architectural diversity which
is evident within a half mile radius of
the site
I've also read all the consultancy
documentation it does appear to me that
there's a divided
on the evolution of the built
environment in and around the proposed
priority site this haven't been said I
know that four times as many members of
the public
uh wrote to support this proposal
compared to votes who wrote to object
furthermore there are several examples
of development in Lebanon which is
outside the buab
or inside a Conservation Area
the most important element of my support
that is application will be a proposed
profitably a true Eco house a built to
passive power specification is now of
course completely obvious to all that
time is running up to address effects of
climate change
whereas the vast majority of Housing
Development is driven by the requirement
of developers to make profits here we
have a proposal which is driven by the
principles of sustainability harmony
with the landscape and minimizing the
effects of the environment in the long
term
if approved this application will result
in an iconic Eco house bill I suspect to
the highest standards termed equality
and sustainability
it will act as a replica blueprint for
future development in the baber region
Robert Lindsay Suffolk County and Berber
District councilor recently stated we
declared a climate emergency in baber
but it really does have to apply to all
aspects of what a council does including
planning planning is the way we say how
our future homes are built and I have a
massive impact on the amount of carbon
we emit
by the council's own mission and I quote
it does recognize its responsibility to
do more
here is an opportunity to do more so I
urge a committee to take an enlightened
decision and Grant approval for this
scheme as a benchmark for future
sustainable housing for my own and
future Generations thank you for the
opportunity to speak
[Applause]
thank you very much sir thank you
members
have you any questions for the speaker
yeah I will do actually uh Mr
premchandwan
um so you're you're sorry you're what
are you studying architecture
architecture at the moment right okay so
um obviously lavanum is absolutely Awash
with six seven eight hundred year old
houses
have you any idea or any notion with
with this particular design being as
modern and as it is what its lifespan
might might be any ideas
it's a Subterranean house I expect
it'll be
compared to the other homes developing
the lavender moment it will definitely
have a higher lifespan and
then one so I expect a couple hundred
years
thank you
any other questions members
no
thank you very much thank you thank you
we now have uh the applicant agent
Jonathan Hill
and I see Mr wine Mark as well so
between you uh you've got three minutes
in your help with the questions thank
you
thank you chair thank you committee
um my wife and I have lived in Lebanon
for nine years and um we let out the
South and the East wing of our home
lavender Priory to provide luxury
accommodation for hundreds of worldwide
visitors each year demand far outstrips
supply for our accommodation offering we
wish to build an Eco house within our
grounds this could then expand our
accommodation offering providing obvious
economic benefits to the area that
increased employment and tourism would
bring
we had originally planned to seek
consent for the large 2010 scheme a much
bigger and more prominent property than
the one that we are now seeking consent
for the 2010 scheme or indeed multiple
smaller units of that scheme would
provide a much higher economic value for
us however over the last five years we
have become very aware of the unique
setting of our home
and its grounds and we want to build
something I.E this smaller property
which is more suitable in the context of
its surroundings and its setting there
are a few important points that come
from comments that have been made on the
planning portal
it is an undeniable fact that the con
the character of the conservation area
around The Priory site has already been
fundamentally Changed by the approval
and construction of the Bears line
development
to answer the question that was put to
the representative of the parish council
there are no views from anywhere except
our grounds
um
the Bear's line development which is
outside the built up area and very
visible from the defined views in and
out of the village has had a negative
effect on lavanum it's defined views and
on the setting of the grade one listed
Priory
um national and local planning policy
does allow for development outside and
well related to the built-up area
boundary in accordance with nppf
paragraph 11 local plan cs11 and the
lavender neighborhood development plan
that is a fact as evidenced by the
granting of the consent for the Bear's
line development
we do understand that historic England
and the beibune district Heritage team
have concerns
however those concerns are predicated on
largely on the top topography the site
10 years ago as evidenced in those
concerns being repeated pretty much in a
replicable form from the application 10
years ago and at that time the appeal
inspector relating to the larger scheme
even then accepted that there would be
no harm to the historic buildings in
Water Street
this application site and the new
darling dwelling cannot be seen from any
defined views and therefore has no
detrimental impact on them and does not
conflict with the lavanum neighborhood
development plan
sustainable design and construction
methodology will be planned and
minimized
to ensure that there's little traffic to
and from the site is possible and a
detailed construction I'm sorry your
time is up so okay I'm gonna stop you uh
remember your time have you got any uh
questions you'd like to put to Mr Hill
uh councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman a little bit
puzzled
.com
um I see that on the front of the uh
recommendations
you
had the on the application you decided
not to take the pre-application advice
would that have been a help to you or
have you you know I I would have thought
that you would have gone for a preact
before the uh I know it's been before
the the planning department but would
that have helped you
I lost my agent to answer that question
uh we we did consider some preamp
so I would do consider pre-app but
bearing in mind also the appeal decision
the previous application there were a
few areas we thought really had to be
dealt with I felt that we'd probably
best do that in devising a scheme of
more details about just putting that
forward we did have some initial
discussion with the parish council just
to Canvas their views before we submit
an application but so our idea was that
we we thought or expected that we
possibly would have some resistance so
we thought we would just go straight
with the details key the best way we
could
thank you it might be worth adding to
that counselor to the extent that we
submitted an original scheme and
that was submitted earlier in 2019
we withdrew that scheme because of the
level of Consulting feedback that we had
and we have systematically tried in the
scheme that's currently before you to
take into account each and every
objection that was raised in respect of
the earlier 2019 scheme
thank you any other questions councilor
Jameson good afternoon you say that
um by building your project development
will delays for you to rent out more of
the priority improving the local economy
do you have any estimates on how much
benefit this will give to the local
economy
um it's probably important to put this
into context The Priory has been used
prior to our ownership
between the early 90s and 2015. it was
used in its entirety as as a boutique
Guest House Bed and Breakfast
accommodation call it what you will
the owners of The Priory at that time
sought consent for the 2010 scheme for a
very very large house further
up the hill
members will remember as you walk up the
Avenue which is the proposed access the
2010 scheme was directly in front of you
whereas our scheme is down towards the
eastern boundary
and so
we know and have
um some very clear economic evidence of
the economic economic activity that The
Priory was generating when it was used
solely for the purposes of letting
and
at that time the priorities supported uh
three sorry two and a half full-time
equivalent employees
um and in terms of income generated
generated approximately three times the
uh income that we currently generate
from the very limited letting that we're
able to accommodate we are able to
accommodate a limited number of guests
because the priority is our home we live
in the main section of The Priory
um I think I think we've got the answer
to your question Council Jameson
um any other questions
the 2010 scheme that was referred and
the inspector commented on on views
could you just repeat what you said
uh yes the
um
I cannot quote directly from the uh
inspectors letter but no don't worry
about it I'll get the officer to do that
in due course but I think that what what
the inspector said
um very clearly was that there would be
no harm to the historic properties in
Water Street that is a view that has
been promoted that there would be harm
to properties in Water Street but
knowing the land intimately as we
obviously do I can confirm that there
will be no harm to any properties in
Water Street
thank you uh so just to be clear to
Carry On from here can you confirm do
you know vote that comment
um yes in yes indom papers the appeal
decision is actually there for you to
see in full so it's probably paragraphs
24 and 25 that you would want to refer
to
um however as I said at the start of the
presentation this is not to do with
visual context this is to do with
principle of development actually sorry
that wasn't the question the question
was at the view and I will deal with
that thank you I think your point of
members to the relevant paragraphs
um I I can quote from the appeal
inspectors that it should members
require me to do so that is members have
that and that wasn't the question that
councilor Buzz be asked you any other
questions
no thank thank you then
sorry members we have a letter from
councilor Margaret maybe which we're
going to read out it's very brief and
then I'll go to the other
um local member which is councilor arfi
I know he's right at the back but uh
we'll let him oh you're going to come
down good
okay
so councilor Margaret Mayberry said she
extends her apologies to the planning
committee for not attending the meeting
this morning
and she wishes to give the following
comments on the planning application
whilst being an active supporter of
innovative and potential iconic
buildings I have given this application
much thought however I do not believe
that this site is suitable for such
development being within the grounds of
such historical importance for the
village of latinum my major concern is
the overlaying of an access point
through the site together with the
impact of harm to the original building
and the extending out of the village
settlement boundary I therefore do not
support this application and urge the
committee to hold the officer's
recommendation to refuse planning applic
planning permission in Council Mabry
thank you very much for that she's not
here so we can't put any questions uh
councilor arfi
uh you're going to come down good
and now a little bit further down
because you're not a member of the
public
yeah this end
come down the sound a bit more where the
members tend to sit
the world members yes that's lovely
thank you then we're not making any
exceptions for you
cancer laughing because I'm sure you're
well aware I have five minutes and
questions will be
um remain seated our service any
questions for you at the end of it
thanks very much chairman yeah I've sat
at the back and listened and I've made a
few notes as a result of what I've heard
this morning you've heard from the
applicant and in my view his proposal
would have a much reduced impact
compared to the previously withdrawn
application and it's also a significant
Improvement on the previously refused
application and you have the inspector's
report for that in in your pack
I also believe it offers the opportunity
for greater public enjoyment and
appreciation of The Priory by releasing
The Priory accommodation to visitors
but you have to balance that against the
impact on the conservation area and the
Heritage concerns
the impact on the conservation area was
an issue addressed by the inspector in
his report at paragraph 26 where he said
the character of the conservation area
would neither be preserved nor enhanced
by that proposal at the time
the Heritage concerns expressed by
Natural England and the Heritage team
are reproduced in your papers
lastly I ask you to give appropriate
weights to the adopted neighborhood plan
for lavanum and the views of the parish
council who prepared it you've heard a
representative from the parish council
speak this morning
he was asked a question and I think the
question was about their policy H1 and
how many of the aspects of that policy
applied to this application so I will
just repeat for you what that policy
says it says that the scale and
character of proposals should respect
the landscape landscape features
streetscape and townscape Heritage
assets important spaces and historic
views into and out of the village
thank you
thank you very much
members have you any questions to put to
cancel that arfi
councilor Busby I'm glad you read that
out
the word that we all seem to be looking
for this one is respect and enhance
things like that but you said respect in
terms of hn1 do you not think that this
design
totally respects where it's being
proposed
I think there's a comment in your in
your papers from the case officer I
think it's from the case officer where
it might be the Heritage response
um it's a paragraph 6.3 I think am I
right there
I haven't got it all in front of me but
I think it was at 6.3
um which comments on on something
described as a gouge in the conservation
area
um so I think what you're getting at
with your question is the The Proposal
is very low impact and I would agree
with that I came on the site visit and I
think we all stood at the top of the
hill and looked at the the um the
artist's impression of what you would
see instead of the shed that currently
exists there and the answer is you would
see very very little you'd see a green
roof which looks very much like a slope
of green grass but I think the the
comment about the the sort of dropped
area to accommodate a drive and the
impact of that on the conservation I
think is quite relevant and is quite
visible I think you were the one on the
site visit that commented that from the
footpath you can't actually see through
the fence so therefore you wouldn't see
any of the the site
but I think it's important to note that
there are several public viewpoints for
that site I pointed out at the site
visit brentily road I don't know if any
of you know the view from Brent City
Road or have taken the the time to have
a look at it since the site visit but
that was one that you weren't able to
appreciate then the other thing that I
think is probably worth saying is that
the fence has been erected quite
recently it does hinder views in into
the site whether that that fence stays
there forever who knows
um
that's I think you're one of the things
you have to assess
any other questions
no
thank you very much counselor
yes you can't comment anymore
right members
um I just want to introduce to to Dr
duck which you all know and Thomas
Pinner their Heritage and Carmel Giselle
who
okay they're here to answer any
particular question you put
um so members are snare over to you for
debate
uh councilor McCall
thank you Chad
um since a lot of this seems to revolve
around uh
Heritage assets and Views I wonder if we
could see again or have talked through
the views described in paragraph 911 uh
the Viewpoint c d and e and possibly I
think there's also another reference to
views elsewhere in the Heritage report I
just wonder if if that aspect could be
brought to the to the Fall by the
Heritage team
hey yes if you can limit it to those
points
thanks chair
um yes so um in the harm I've identified
I consider that some aspects of that is
related to views
and that was in relation to the Views
that might exist if that fence that has
been erected
um was to be lost in the future
um fences have such a long lifespan as I
say a dwelling but I also consider that
there is a harm that's independent of
views and I can just perhaps the clarify
a point that often comes up
in relation to that is as if I can quote
a section of the national planning
practice guidance on views it's talking
about setting and it can apply to
character and appearance of conservation
areas as well
um so it says the extent and importance
of setting is often expressed by visual
reference to visual relationship between
the asset and the proposed development
and Associated visual physical
considerations although views of or from
an asset will play an important part in
the assessment of impacts of setting the
way in which we experience an asset in
its setting is also influenced by other
environmental factors
such as noise does smell and vibration
and from land use uses a vicinity and by
our understanding of the historical
relationship between places which I
think is a brilliant Point here and also
the contribution that setting makes to
the significance of a Heritage asset
does not depend on their being public
rights of way or an ability to otherwise
access or experience that setting the
contribution may vary over time
thank you
um uh just to really I was hoping for
something more visual if they don't mind
please um viewpoints C D and E are
described from the visual impact
assessment I wonder if we have any
slides that would be relevant to those
viewpoints
uh so this is one of the viewpoints from
brentie the road up towards the village
So Into The Village
and then this one looking out across the
landscape from bears Lane
so because God has just before
27 and 28 the side is the other side of
what we're looking at is that correct
it's on the left hand side right yeah
yes right that's what so you can't see
the site at where you're shown as that's
the point that we're trying to get at uh
yes
um so I just come back on
um
of course point on the uh reviews I
referred to they were from uh the I
think an appraisal that's done by by the
applicant agent and they reviews they
were inside their Garden land but close
to the boundary so I considered that
they might provide a a reasonable
assessment of what the view just the
other side on the footpath might be if
the the vegetation and the and the
fencing wasn't there
thank you right councilor Parker
um Channel I'm going to contribute a
little further but um I just to to my
mind and in my opinion this is not about
views
um chair this is um this is about the
setting uh and and um I think we're
we're missing perhaps we're missing that
point but I'll rejoin the debate in a
bit
you can have your say no we can go under
settings
oh right uh is there other members who
want to comment on the councilor plum
thank you chair can I ask the Heritage
team to develop a little bit more of
this thoughts about Black Background
development proposed in Water Street
you've seem to be very keen for this not
to occur and is that the country of this
matter after all
uh yes I think that is a relevant point
and I think in this case with the the
amount of the lack of backline
development in certain parts of Lebanon
between the historic medieval Corps and
the open uh green spaces
um is an important and quite quite
unique aspect of this area is part of
lavenum conservation area's character
thank you
any other comments councilor Busby Yeah
you mentioned the word historic
relationship uh or Worse historic
relationship between the buildings
and it maybe me but I actually see that
having two totally polar Opera opposites
actually enhances the thing
you wouldn't try and
um
work with a building like The Priory and
put something else up that was in in
competition with it a modern building
that stands well up or in an older
building you wouldn't try and
match it or or say compete with it this
one is totally opposite and you I would
argue that it it's so opposite it
enhances and is sympathetic
with this historic building it's it's
like stating now
this will be a Heritage asset
in 150 200 years and it'd be interesting
to see the relationship between this
modern building and the historic one I
think that relationship is important
um I consider that this site is
important it makes a contribution to the
conservation area as an undeveloped
space so whether or not the new building
may be considered a Heritage asset in
the future I can see it at the same time
it's it removing and eroding the
um the contribution that this site makes
is an undeveloped green space with no
development I'm on it at the moment
yes
thank you Jerry if I could just add a
add an aside I've I've not experienced a
case where an inspector or a Heritage
team has ever or historical England to
my experience has ever advocated their
development within the grounds of a
building that has never been developed
will enhance the setting this building
has sat backing onto medieval Fields
Land open land and Paddock as we
describe here since its conception we
have no Maps evidence to the contrary to
build something in the grounds whatever
it is I cannot in all conscience believe
that it can enhance the setting the
setting is the medieval Street relating
to this sorry but surely that's an
opinion
um that that's a deal because I think
it's based on I think the point that
councilor Busby's bacon is that his is
he's got the view that it can enhance
and you're saying that it can't but
that's your view well and in my
experience and my my understanding from
the advice historic England had given me
for 22 years and an appeals that I've
been involved with
that's never happened
if if we take if we take a look at the
view from The Priory
regardless of whether this building's
built or not if that fence wasn't there
which is one of the things you're saying
is only temporary you would actually see
out under the new development on bear
Lane
now that has harmed the views that has
significantly changed the Outlook of an
historic building
much more than one which you can't see
because it's buried in the ground lower
than the actual Priory so you know the
damage has almost been done
and I can't comment on that because I
wasn't involved with that case and I
don't I don't know the case history
nevertheless if damage has been done
the there's no policy that suggests that
we should reinforce that damage by
further development if it's been done
let's try and mitigate let's not amplify
and now in terms of the issue of the
fence the fence we've determined is PD
unfortunate but we think it's PD if it
isn't PD then the the applicant might
have to remove it this is only academic
he could put back a hedge there tomorrow
and to do the same to serve the same
purpose but the the harm as you say been
done we shouldn't be seeing we shouldn't
be overseeing an amplification of that
harm by developing within the grounds of
this very highly graded listed buildings
in what is probably the best village in
the joint districts
thank you
Council Barrett
hadn't thought sorry counselor Busby I
thought you finished
counselor Barrett you go next please
the question is slightly different so um
just wanted to refer to papers
um
on
the officers reports
um let's see if I've got it here
um right on page 60 we've got a summary
of
um objections I believe those oral
objections that are listed and
summarized but we've also got apparently
37 support comments but have we got
those listed anywhere or summarized
anywhere
as a general rule we don't we don't
actually put the support comments in
just the number that we've received
they were
many of them were not local
representations and I suspect many of
them were guests
from The Priory
uh I think that's perhaps irrelevant
we've had 37 letters of support and I
think we must take note of that and
we've had these views that are against
which are listed out there
it doesn't help you
right uh councilor Busby
okay so looking at the officer's
conclusion
again this is one of these balancing
items isn't it
Heritage team have stated that it's less
than substantial harm
okay so it's on the lower scale
there are more significant levels of
harm than less than substantial
uh less than substantial harm can you
clarify that yes Chad as we've said
before and the the enormous percentage
of all developments that harm the
setting or the significance of a list of
building in any way is less than
substantial harm that is the definition
of historic England news it's simply
it's a mechanism to Define that
something that hasn't been effectively
demolished or has has had visited upon
it
um an enormous sort of hemorrhage
something that's really really
catastrophic to the significance that is
substantial harm that happens in
possibly one percent of all listed
building cases where there's harm in the
other 99 percent there is less than
substantial harm and there is a spectrum
within that which we have to Define
between ourselves regarded by historic
England but there is a spectrum from
negligible all the way up to medium and
high levels of less than substantial but
something that is a high high level of
less and substantial harm is is
effectively perhaps the equivalent of
taking my arm off you know it's it's
taking off a wing of a historic building
or it's seriously damaging a medieval
setting of a building that is less than
substantial all the way down to changing
the front door from one color to another
that might be a negligible level of harm
all those things are within that
spectrum of less than substantial the
tiny amount of development that is
substantial harm includes demolition or
catastrophic loss of significance which
is basically demolition
so
I might have missed it but could you
place in your spectrum
where this one is
because I didn't get that oh yeah so I
think it might say I identified a medium
level of less than substantial harm
and yeah so lesson essentially is still
a high bar
[Music]
all right thank you so it's it's still a
balancing item on that side you've got a
medium level of less than substantial
and on the other side you've got the
public benefit
and we have to determine what that
public benefit is and from what I say it
is it's a greater use of an historic
acid which I would have thought was a
good thing
uh it's increased employment
it's increases the to the economy of
lavenum
so there are a few plus things on the
other side of the equation
it isn't straightforward don't do it
thank you
um our service over other questions
because we need to move on any other
questions members
yes yep
thank you chair perhaps somebody can
answer this to me we're talking about a
building with a garage and obviously to
get a car to a garage you need a roadway
what harm would be to this Meadow with a
roadway running right through the middle
of it because what I can remember it
when we were on site it was quite a nice
sorry it was quite spectacular in some
ways and in terms of talking about
intrusion onto listed buildings Etc I
just thought tearing that up to put a
track in place to run a car down to a
garage would have far more impact any
comment I think it's a little heavy to
say roadway it's a um it's a driveway to
a dwellin
um I I think it's a bit heavier
uh any other uh comments uh councilor
Parker
thank you chair
um right so we've we've been out we've
had a look at the plans and they look
absolutely spectacular there's no doubt
about it this is um absolutely the the
sort of uh dwelling and premises that we
should be looking to encourage
um uh you know in in our district it's a
real departure
unfortunately there is a huge body of
um policy uh that tells us that we
shouldn't be supporting this application
and that you know it's highly regretful
but I do have to concur with a
particularly with our heritage officers
on on this particular case
um
furthermore rather rather
disappointingly one thing that we
haven't even discussed or touched upon
um is the good people of laughing on
themselves and and the fact that they do
have a neighborhood plan and I think
that the speaker
smoke very eloquently that lavinum have
gone to a great deal of of time and
attention in producing their
neighborhood plan and their plan is very
clear
[Music]
um and I think to undermine that as a
local Authority
um without a significant
counter body of evidence to do so will
indeed undermine the Democratic process
entirely so
um
I'm actually going to propose again uh
chair that we go with the officer's
recommendation uh on on this occasion
and refuse her permission thank you very
much for that councilor Parker do I have
a second to counselor McCord to do Mr
comment yes I'd like to second that and
I'd just like to draw members attention
in doing so I'm particularly impressed
with points made about policy H1 from
the latinum neighborhood plan and the
first two items that councilor arathi
referred to about the scale and
character and about making a positive
contribution to the local character
shape and scale of the area a positive
contribution not a reduced negative
if this is not a positive it is a better
negative but it's probably inappropriate
so I support the
thank you any other comments members
otherwise I can't slope Osborne yeah so
thank you Mr chairman I have every
sympathy with the
um
owner of that property and I do like
that I do like the way it's been
constructed in that area it's
unfortunate that we're dealing with a
Heritage issue and I go along with with
what heritage have said and obviously on
the previous applications that have been
refused and gone to Jr but
I'm I've got to say that I I in a way
I'm I'm
upset in a way that it couldn't be
applied to in this case so I'm afraid
I'm going to stick with the officer's
recommendation
thank you
if there's no other comments then I'll
intend to put it to the vote it's been
proposed and seconded that we followed
the officer's recommendation for refusal
all those in favor of refusal please
show
those against
thank you very much that is carrieve
that application is refused
fine thank you
right members we're going to carry on
um
oh well I'm sorry he knows
where'd you come to Purdue
has he gone
oh forget it right
uh we're now on page velocity just now
page 75 uh how you paint a Melford Road
Subway Suffolk
um just before we start this members I'm
going to read out a statement because
there's been a lot of emails and
correspondence uh backwards and souls to
myself and officers the baber planning
Charter under Section 5 states that
discussions between an applicant and the
council prior to a submission of a plan
and permission can be of considerable
benefits to both parties this is
encouraged
continued discussions and negotiations
between the council and an applicant
after submission of proposals is
commonplace and an important part of the
planning process
officers communicate with all relevant
parties whether they are the applicant
objector or Parish Council
and I feel that it's only right and
proper that we should engage wherever
possible with the community
further to this I wish to put on record
that I fully support the officer in this
case and the approach that he and his
colleagues have taken thank you
[Applause]
right well now we're going to the office
of concerned and councilor Wilkinson
will you take us through it
thank you chair good afternoon members
and members of the public I'm Jack
Wilkinson I'm a principal planning
officer in the DM service your next item
is item 6D as chairs pointed out at page
this item has already been to committee
we have indeed carried out a site
inspection as well on a rainy day
pre-Christmas
it's a full plans planning application
with all the detail
five dwellings garages
Landscaping improvements to the internal
access and the frontage
but
so just to jog your memory this site is
towards the north of Sudbury
[Applause]
set on an elongated piece of land which
adjoins Milford Road it's 0.79 hectare I
will probably skim through
um some photos with regards to the site
given that we've been on site and it's
been presented already but for clarity
we can go back to that if necessary
we're situated towards the edge of the
built-up area boundary as you can see
the uh brown colored line is the
existing local pattern
boundary the emerging local plan which
is of limited weight at this stage does
include this parcel of land which is
shown we've got some Tipo trees to the
north and also grade one asset here the
mill
oh
for clarity the defined Redline outline
and in terms of the actual site layouts
we'll go straight into that I think key
features to note our plots
one to five so one at the front which is
Affordable which I'll go into in a
minute plot two three four and five
towards the rear of the site an internal
Private Road
and indeed the axis which is a point of
contention I think members asked us to
defer last time out to seek a better
resolution I will come on to the detail
in that in a moment there's also a track
which leads up the southern Fringe of
the site which leads to the grade to
listed Mill
You may wish to follow me with these
photos we've got the site plan on the
bottom left-hand corner with an arrows
showing where these photos were taken
from
and I will skip through given that we've
been on site happy to go back at any
point
should you consider it necessary
it's a view facing north
prominent trees towards the northern
boundary which are TPO protected but
these are off-site
so back to the plan
and it's necessary just to highlight the
affordable unit here this site extends
above 0.5 hectare
and that threshold means that the
applicant is required to provide
affordable housing and we have secured
that that will be through section 106 as
in your papers
it's quite a generous plot as well along
with detached garage so that's quite a
welcome design and layout detail I'd say
these are the house types
um I'll start off with the affordable
unit these are quite a welcome palette I
suppose of tonal colors and indeed
materials page 84 of your papers gives
you a nice breakdown of of what
materials are to be used which You may
wish to refer to
there's the open market units
sensible rendered finish
with good layouts so again back to the
plan to the front there is some
um Landscaping proposed and in addition
throughout the site
apologies it's not the clearest but this
is a a retaining area which would sit at
the front
given the uh the landslope as well
that's entirely necessary
I'd like to kind of talk now about the
highways aspects
so you'll recall we stood in this area
here as shown by the red marker pavement
opposite the site
current access
as existing which is to proposed to be
configured so that it is acceptable for
five units
this is the view facing north and this
is the view facing south into Sudbury
so you'll see there the slope
now in terms of definitive plan this is
the proposed access
and with the measurements on the
configuration
is acceptable to the local highways
Authority so I will reiterate this was
acceptable last time out
the configuration has not changed
we are now back here to discuss another
element which I'll talk about
so in terms of the actual approved plans
this isn't really helpful for you
because it's really difficult to read
but that is the defined plan with the
visibility splays
I'm going to use the aerial map because
it's clearer but effectively you can see
the central point where the access is
now rarely
you'd expect a 90 meter visibility
Supply in both directions in an urban
area and I'll leave you to decide
whether this is urban or Rural and this
is 30 mile an hour as well you're only
required to provide 43 meters this
scheme provides 90 in both directions so
it is way above and beyond highways
compliant in terms of visibility
now this is the aspect that the
applicant has paid careful attention to
following the deferral last time out
here is the access point
which is by the way compliant
pedestrians have the option of standing
here crossing the roads and utilizing
the footpath
they also now have an option of
utilizing the footpath on the same side
of the road
which links to Canterbury Road
which I've chosen to highlight in yellow
just for ease this is the defined plan
this is The Pedestrian roots on the same
side
and the highlights in blue with abrasive
material
and it's an entirely workable solution
that we would secure through planning
condition and which the highways team
are on board with
this is a frontage
with the proposed
pedestrian path
this is a view looking north towards the
access
which is approximately here
and with the overlay which I've included
which hopefully provides context you can
see roughly where that path is going to
go this is all fixed by a defined plan
I will leave you with a final summary
some facts and figures to consider
overall the scheme is acceptable subject
to the conditions bound within the
report
welcome any questions and the
recommendation is for approval
thank you chair
just before you leave that pint uh last
time you were sent away to have
discussions regarding whether we could
bring in the road from the top as well
you can just briefly come out
I think that's a conversation that was
had certainly chair
um
we as the local planning Authority
reserve the right to engage with
applicants under the mppf power 48 we
have done that
um I think due to land ownership that
was not a viable option
um certainly the question was posed to
the agent but we have to determine
what's in front of us and that's what
your officer's recommendation is thank
you very much that's very clear uh right
we don't have any technology
I want to go to the speakers first and
then I'll come to
so I need to come back Mr chairman to
ask the solicitor uh sorry yeah okay do
your bit no do that now yeah thank you
very much for that Mr chairman
um it's basically that um my wife is one
Ward member here and although My Views
are open on this I just would like to
take advice as to whether I should
actually not take any further part with
with this particular application
it would be a bit old-fashioned to take
a strong view of this I think if you're
quite happy that you have
and independent judgments it will be I
wouldn't advise you otherwise
yeah we have quite a few arguments but
never about planning
you are an elective counselor in your
own right anyway it's down to you uh
right uh Town Council we have no one uh
objector Mr Peter Terry so you have
three minutes in which to address the
committee if you'd like to come forward
thank you
it's a one to the right yep
good afternoon
German Constance
the last time we came here there was a
vote on this proposal
it was rejected 74.
but it was decided that we should look
again at the safety
aspects they all hinge round has been
pointed out they you know the safety of
that access onto Melford Road
yeah
the
it's one of the problems with plans is
that don't show elevations
and there's an elevation problem coming
from the roundabout along Melford into
Sudbury the ground Rises up
and also as
by indication we're talking about the
south bank there's a big Bank along that
area it is not easy to see to the right
and if you're in a car sitting at that
sort of level you cannot see easily to
the right side
the present people who live in the
middle and use that exit have to pour
well into the Carriage Way before they
can you know proceed
Milford Road is busy busy busy you can
hardly walk across it at times
it is interesting that there's been a
lot of development in Sudbury behind the
chaucerer estate and none of that
development was allowed to exit onto
Melford Road
even they all have to go via the Tesco
roundabout
even to the extent there was a barrier
put across there
so that you know traffic pedestrians
come but traffic can't come down there
the other thing is that this walkway I
mean we said is that uh is it any used
the Town Council decided it wouldn't be
used it was too torturous
I went wrong further I asked a group of
skilled school children
if you lived over there would you use
this and the answer is no it's too
roundabout it's too indirect
it doesn't solve the problem and it does
actually
terminate on Canterbury Road which okay
is a lot less traffic on there but it
doesn't terminate at a pavement it
terminates at a road
yeah I just think it's too Hazard I
think I think because you people have a
duty of care to perspective occupants of
those houses and I don't think it's I
mean I live at number one Canterbury
Road I oversee I look over this
and it's and it's just too unsafe
and I don't want you people to think
yeah in months time yeah what did we do
we approve that the people who have been
a number of applications uh on that
piece of land and they've all been
rejected because of access onto Melford
Road
thank you Mr Terry your time is up I'll
service any questions to you uh members
have you any questions
no
okay thank you very much there's no
questions thank you
um with no supporter with no applicant
or agent
and with no County counselor uh
we have an email from counselor Jan
Osborne which I would go get read out
I I haven't heard from councilor Trevor
Creswell
thank you chair so I'll just read out
the email from councilor Osborne
um
apologize for being unable to attend
today due to a prior appointment that
cannot be changed and would ask these
comments are read out
I would like it to be known that I
absolutely support growth in baber but
it has to be the right homes in the
right place
this at the access is completely
inappropriate as it is from and on to a
very busy road
one of the main roads into Sudbury where
the speed limit is very often exceeded I
appreciate the efforts have been made by
the applicant to mitigate concerns
regarding the lack of pedestrian
provision
to and from this development however I
still feel that the changes made do not
address this concern I would urge the
committee to consider my comments and
refuse this application councilor Jan
Osborne
thank you
uh she's not here to ask questions
so we won't go down that road
um
councilor Barrett thank you um yeah can
you describe to us again and perhaps
show us that
a small image you had of the sort of
blocks that were at the front of the
site and explain exactly where they are
and uh
huh
conveniently I'll probably start here if
I may so in terms of the retainer it
would operate from this point so looking
right out of the proposed access
and if I skip back
they will run
pretty much roughly where the The Verge
is here at the minute so you'll be
seeing it here the visibility will be
clear and you'll have a retaining area
along the frontage
naturally the land does incline as with
much of the remainder of the estate to
the South there's going to be an element
of retain
retirement there
I'm not sure if that's clear enough
hopefully that does help
so that's intended to increase the
visibility as you look right as you exit
the the site
indeed there'll be an element of the
bank that's cut out and it'll be
retained
any other questions
thank you um a sort of a question but
when we have the last site visit
unfortunately it's during the school
holidays
and I have grandchildren along that road
and in school term time it's a jolly
site busier my second question is the
ownership of that land that they want to
build the path across
we haven't got the perspective here I
don't know who it belongs to
thank you for your question I think the
first part in terms of it being busy I
don't dispute that Melford road is a
busy road
I think the response from the applicant
to ensure that there's not one but two
options is is commendable to be honest
the first access that came to committee
was accepted by the local highways
Authority they've gone back and revised
that with an additional footpath on the
same side to Canterbury Road that is
also compliant
undeliverable as well that Verge is
owned by the County Council and that
open space is owned by the county that
would be secured through Section 278 and
for the means of planning it will be
through condition
very good thank you Council of Nicole
I'd just like to ask Jack of the
footpath on the south side of the site
does that also lead I mean the one
running the length of the site does that
lead anywhere
oh
indeed um it's actually a vehicular
access that's used by residents of the
mill which sits to the East and that's
their principal access
um single track but you may know from
the layout that the site proposed here
only utilizes a small section of it so
they would retain you know the
predominant use of that because the the
access kinks in and you're into sight
what I'm asking is is there a further
access to the site so that to the
opposite end is the only way in and out
of this on what I would say is looking
at the map the west side I hope that's
right it's the north south map isn't it
you're absolutely right access from the
West Side via Melford Road one way in
one way out and the same for the
footpath one way one way out thank you
uh it comes into hell thank you chair I
think I'm quite impressed I was here at
the last meeting when this was
sorry
um I was at the last meeting
and I think the applicant has actually
gone out of his way to improve the um
the footpath that was my concern and is
to be commended if he's got visibility
displays of 90 meters which we don't
seem to achieve in other planning
applications
Bill
any other comments councilor Barrett can
I also just check
um where the 30 mile hour sign appears
on on that road how near is it
I believe it's from the roundabout so as
you turn as you go head north
apologies it's just off shot from the
photos that I took but you are well
within the 30 mile an hour Zone I think
by Nature because it's straight Vehicles
do take Liberties and perhaps go beyond
that sometimes
thank you
councilman tomorrow okay again I'm just
still kind of focusing on the access
points um it would seem to me it'd be a
good sight for a mirror of system
opposite across the road as we have some
in my locality I'm sure other members
have them as well if there is any fear
about access from the north and speeding
the other thing is the it was implied
um in something we heard from an
objector that there was no footpath on
Canterbury Road is that surely that
surely can't be correct he says it's a
road presumably there is a pavement on
that road is there not
um I think your first question about
mirrors highways Furniture
um it falls outside of our remit we
would have a wish list but unfortunately
that's not before us and certainly the
uh proposed footpath included within
this application would link to an
established footpath which is properly
curbed Unbound
any other comment members
no uh councilor Barrett can I recommend
approval
but do I have a secondary councilor I
can I do wish to say anything
no you said it okay
uh no other comments then
it's been proposed and seconded that we
approved the officer's recommendation as
set out in your papers all those in
favor please show
those against
two that is carried thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
let me go on to the next one right now
all right campus we're now moving on to
uh what Elm set
little e and that's on page 195.
uh Elizabeth again
thank you so this is an application for
37 dwellings and creation of a regular
access road and public open spaces uh
you'll note that there are various late
papers for this application including a
letter of support from solicitors
working for the applicant you'll note on
that letter that in point four they've
just talked about an amended plan just
to make clear that we haven't accepted
any amended plans and the plans to be
assessed are the ones that we use for
the report under shown on this
PowerPoint you'll also see there is a
response from the parish council to that
letter of support
um this application you have previously
seen this site because there was a
previous application for 43 dwellings
which was determined in 2018 and is
currently at appeal
so the key issues are whether there is
evidence of local need for the
development in accordance with EMS T1
and cs11 and also the housing mix and
the impact on protected views under the
elm set neighborhood plan
so
this is the site
see it's just currently agricultural
land
this is the neighboring property the
checkers the listed building this is the
mobile home park next to it and then you
can see that there's more built
development on the opposite side of the
road and along here
this site is currently it's in the old
Nursery site which is currently being
developed for new dwellings you can see
some pictures of those
again this shows the site location plan
the main village and the facilities are
sort of further up this road
uh this shows the constraints so the
built-up area boundary currently goes
along here
and then around the mobile home park and
then along here
you'll also note on here Checkers the
grade two listed no um listed building
adjacent to the site
this shows the site layout so it's quite
a straightforward layout this is the
attenuation Basin located here what's
happened between this and the previous
plan is that the density has decreased
with the number of dwellings being
dropped and this means that there can
now be space between the development and
the listed building which has meant that
the
Heritage officer is now lowered his his
harm and he now feels that there will be
inevitable harm on the listed building
and this second public open space is
also been created which is sort of in
line with other developments along
Hearts along this road along whatfield
road which have greens to the front the
affordable housing is located here as a
block here and then two shared ownership
opposite
and there's also another set of shared
ownership dwellings here
and you'll notice the other public open
space would be in this location so the
dwellings would look over the public
open space there would be this road and
then there'll be a second set of
dwellings overlooking this area public
open space
uh these are just the
um
house types I'll just go through this
quickly these are the shared ownership
affordable dwellings
again that's the other pair of shared
ownership affordable dwellings you'll
note on these that these are quite
similar to the market houses
these are the affordable houses for rent
so there's some Bungalows these are one
bedroom bungalows
then there's some houses
um there's still two bed and three bed
dwellings
um free bed and then these are the
market dwellings so you can see that
there is a more elaborate design for the
um Market dwellings
these ones are sort of Chalet Bungalows
so they provide a couple of bedrooms on
the ground floor and then some more
bedrooms upstairs so that they'll meet a
particular need for for sort of ground
and first four bedrooms
uh these are Bungalows so there will be
some provision of both market and
affordable Bungalows on the site
these are the site the location so this
shows so the protected view
um in um are set out in the elm set
neighborhood flat planet of this sort of
uh Countryside view at the back with
this um
of these trees and so on
um so this is sort of the view that you
get the best view you get from the site
overlooking those
um this is Checkers the listed building
so the development would be this is the
site here
um but this would be where the
attenuation Basin was to give
um a bit of space between the listed
building and the new development
again this has just shows you the front
of checkers and you can see the the
location of the site to the rear
this is looking uh along whatfield road
so this is a development on the other
side of the road and this is the site to
the left
again opposite you can see the
development opposite the site
okay so this um is the new dwellings
going up further up what field road on
the the nursery site so you saw that
on the aerial photograph this just shows
you the surrounding development so this
is the mobile home park so there would
be dwellings just behind these houses
but there would be Bungalows um the
first set of houses will be Bungalows to
protect the immunity of the occupiers of
the mobile home site it's a permanent
mobile home site
um and then again another view of the
site to the left
and again another view of the
surrounding development and the
recommendation is as set out in your
report to refuse
um due to the lack of evidence of local
need
the loss of
an important view as set out in the
neighborhood plan and the fact that the
mix does not reflect what the
neighborhood plan requires in terms of
small one and two bedroom dwellings
thank you thank you very much for that
um we have public speakers Parish
Council Mr Newman
foreign
Newman Parish chairman the parish has
submitted its comments on this
application and recommended refusal I
trust you have seen our full comments
the main thrust of our objection is that
the development is contrary to the
emerging joint local plan and the newly
made and adopted note neighborhood plan
the neighborhood plan was formally made
by baber as recently as the 12th of
December following the local Village
referendum on the 7th of November
the neighborhood plan is therefore the
up-to-date development plan document in
relation to the development proposals
before you
and it is the starting point for
determination of the application
The Joint emerging local plan and
neighborhood plan are aligned in respect
of housing numbers and site allocations
for the village
this site is not shown in the preferred
options joint local plan document and
we're pleased that all of this is
reflected in your office's
recommendation of refusal
the neighborhood plan allocates around
60 dwellings over the plan period And as
we've stated before there are currently
72 dwellings either in the course of
construction approved or allocated and
that includes over 20 affordable
dwellings
policy EMS T1 spatial strategy should be
adhered to and it states the
neighborhood plan area will accommodate
development commensurate with Elm set's
designation as a hinterland Village in
line with a core strategy policy cs11
the focus for new development will be
within the built up area as defined on
the proposals map the proposals for uh
proposals for development located
outside the built up area will only be
permitted where it can be satisfactorily
demonstrated there is identified need
for the proposal and that it cannot be
satisfactorily located within that built
up area
this application is outside the built up
area and the applicant has not
demonstrated an identified and credible
local need for further major residential
development that would satisfy the
requirement of the adoptive policy
we were encouraged by the overwhelming
show of support for the neighborhood
plan at the referendum and continue to
strongly recommend that proposals be
refused it is simply not needed not
sustainable and is not on a scale with
the cell with the existing settlement
and does not comply with up-to-date
planning notes as late as Monday you
received further comments from the
applicant disputing officers comment and
trying to tarnish the neighborhood plan
we have submitted a rebuttal that deals
with all the points made and commend it
to you thank you for listening
please I'll take any questions thank you
very much missile service center any
questions uh councilors
thank you thank you chair and welcome
um I noticed that the school and
preschool are at capacity
um does that mean that the school is
full there are no places
foreign
preschool is actually closed now and I
believe that there is capacity at the
school at the primary school numbers are
there there is Headroom
the second question
I noticed some houses on the um
side we saw are they being sold well you
said there's no need for more housing
but are the sales of these houses being
built going well
sorry I didn't quite understand what you
were there's some houses are being built
at the present
are they selling well you said you'd
have no need for more housing
we have no need for more housing because
we've got 70 odd um I think it's hard to
interrupt but I'm the values that that's
irrelevant
um so
um we'll move on
uh councilor Parker
thanks yeah um counselor you mentioned
um when you was just speaking then that
uh I think you said that there was um
there was no uh identified need
um our report says that um it's not been
adequately demonstrated that there is an
identified local need so are you aware
that the uh applicant conducted a need
survey at all just to clarify no what
the applicant did was he looked at the
neighborhood plan and the results of the
household survey that we undertook there
which is of course opinion it's not a
housing needs survey where any financial
information is given or ability to pay
us it was stated
thank you
I'd just like to ask just roughly how
many houses there might be in this sort
of in the center of Elton said if you
should know that is just roughly
yeah
um
I think there are about 270 all together
I think I I think that's about the case
but
yeah I think that's about right cool
any other questions
no
thank you very much
and we'll move on we have
um Mr Charles course uh applicant or
agent
would you like to come forward sir
when you're ready
okay thank you chairman uh good morning
my name is Charles course I'm MD of
Heath patch limited the applicant as as
has just been confirmed the elm set
preschool is having to close due to a
lack of young children and also the
village shop is planning to close next
year due to a lack of business um it's
our view that to maintain these vital
local facilities we need to accept that
Villages need to grow and that they need
young people in the local community
James Buckle who's the owner of Heath
patch who is very involved in local
charities in the district and across
Suffolk he was chairman of the Suffolk
Community Foundation and is currently
chairman of the port project in Hadley
he's very keen to help provide more
small affordable houses in the district
and that's been one of the objectives of
this application for some time as has
just been mentioned we've reduced the
number of large open market houses
including removing those next to the
adjacent listed building and replacing
them with open space the site now
includes 18 affordable houses which is
48 affordable
uh we would be prepared to increase the
number of smaller one and two bedroom
properties as outlined in the letter
sent by our planning consultant last
week we would be quite happy to increase
that to 48 or above 50 one and two
bedroomed properties
um to achieve the 48 proposed in the
local in the recent neighborhood plan
whilst we welcome the neighborhood plan
and we've tried to respond to all its
requirements and proposals we don't
think that open view number 10 has any
particular features that warrant its
protection it is just an arable field in
a village with a row of trees at the
back that you can see through a gap in
the Hedge if this is considered to be a
reason for refusing permission we would
really urge members to undertake a site
visit to see this for themselves
as James and Heath coach genuinely want
to provide smaller affordable accessible
housing locally we're prepared to fund
this development the development of this
site ourselves with a housing mix that
many developers would find on viable as
the landowner we are able and willing to
undertake this project and to commence
development as soon as possible if the
committee are minded to prove this
scheme we'd be happy to accept a
condition to commence development more
rapidly
this development is a rare opportunity
for the district to benefit from a large
proportion of smaller and more
affordable houses provided by a local
landowner that wants to and is
fortunately able to afford to help the
local community I'd urge members to
focus on this when deciding on the
application
the committee our mind to approve this
scheme subject to further conditions or
further amendments including further
changes to the housing mix and more
smaller units we would be very happy to
discuss that with the planning officers
this development if undertaken will
deliver a high level of affordable
housing plus further significant smaller
houses one and two bedroom houses and
more Bungalows it would also generate
Sil in excess of a third of a million
pounds obviously very happy to answer
any questions
thank you very much remember so many
questions
counselor Parker
um thank you very much for that um and
it's it's it's refreshing to have a
landowner that's actually prepared to uh
to to build out um themselves so that's
that's you know that's positive in my
opinion but um could you uh give
committee a sense uh of the engagement
that you have undertaken with Village I
mean obviously neighborhood plans in
existence uh that's taken a very long
time to come forward so what what
engagement did you undertake with with
the parish uh we I met with the Parish
Council on quite a few occasions can't
remember how many to have went and
presented the original scheme and talked
to them before we put the original
scheme forward went and talked to the
parish council again attended their
drop-in sessions on the neighborhood
plan and that was and as Alan Newman
just said we we did rely on some of the
information there particularly the
interest in smaller one and two bedroom
properties and Bungalows for retiring
people so we took that on board
um we've talked to people in the village
um we've engaged with the school and the
preschool group and the village school
committee we've we've tried to engage
with the Villagers as much as we can we
like to engage with the village as a as
a local landowner
thank you uh any other questions
no
thank you very much
the local member is a member of the
planning committee so I'll start with
councilor Jameson if you'd like to
thank you chair
um I'll set like the liabilities as has
been said it's always um Services you
know abilities are always at risk so you
know I want to um
consider this application with an open
mind
however it does bring me a number of
concerns
um firstly there is oh under this point
out that the well I'm inside the the
shop as far as I'm aware is closing
because the owners are moving away it's
up for sale it's not through lack of use
uh the yeah this number of concerns the
previous development on this site was
rejected on Heritage grounds
and this application is improved there
is but it is still
um Heritage concerns and in the
documentation hurricanes appointed this
out there's still issues of being so
close to listed building
uh there's the needs is pointed out by
councilor Newman the there's already
several applicants approved applications
approved for development in Elm set for
um over 70 properties
which are some of which are being built
now so there's the need issue
um l-set is likely to lose its bus
service
next month thanks to Southern Council so
we would be putting more traffic on a
single Track Road
and Reliance on
um
the car for sustainability purposes
so that's a concern and what has already
been pointed out by the um by cancer in
London we just adopted the onset
neighborhood plan in the last month
to now go against if we do agree with
this application to go against this I
mean they spent two and a half years on
their neighborhood plan if we do agree
this application it seems to be not just
a slap in the face to the onset Villages
but a slap in the face to all the other
abilities put in neighborhood plans
together at the moment so I do want us
to consider that before
we come to an agreement
um
and yeah I think that's that we've got
to say at the moment thanks thank you
uh any other comments uh councilor
Barrett
thank you um chairman I just wanted to
look at um paragraph 3.6 in our report
on 10 page 102 which talks about
um uh development only being permitted
in an exceptional circumstances subject
to proven justifiable need but then it
says the blanket approach is not
entirely consistent and favors a more
balanced approach
so
um I believe that what you're saying is
is that
um that paragraph is not engaged and we
don't have to purely base our decision
on pure and justifiable needs is I've
got that right
so CS2 is out of date so it has it has
some weight but it has less weight so we
no longer need to prove exceptional
circumstances what has the weight is
cs11 and emsd1 so while in theory
development outside the build-up area
boundary in Elm set could be acceptable
they need to prove the local need and in
this case they have relied on a piece of
evidence from the neighborhood plan
which isn't considered adequate enough
to prove justifiably that there is a
local need for 37 houses
hope that helps you
know uh councilor Parker
um so on that basis
um and it doesn't exist so um throw this
out if you think it's out of order chair
but on that basis
um if the developer had provided that
node survey would that have impacted on
the recommendation
yes it would have if
if through the local need which is what
we ask most development developers in
this case to do that may well have taken
out part one of the um reasons for
refusal we would have still needed to
look at part two and three but yes it
would have if they could approve the
local need it would be in accordance
with cs11 and EMS T1
councilor Barrett you want to come back
just clarify a little bit more
are the other developments that are
taking place at the moment do they
comprise affordable homes
I'm not aware of all of the the home
sites within Elm set it's probably that
most of them don't and then the larger
ones will provide a proportion as
required
and may I just um clarify one point
because I know a little bit about the
school in um elmset and I believe
they've got 58 pupils on their role at
the moment they have
um last year uh reduced their number of
teaching staff because of the falling
role so they they are probably at risk
in the future of closure because
um you know the viability question if
they don't manage to keep numbers
subscribed to the school so that is a
you know that would lead to more pupils
more families leaving the village in
more more Journeys out of the village
daily if the school closed so you know
it plays into the the question about
um more additional Journeys
the infrastructure officer has requested
funding under sale for
um primary school expansion so
because they put that in their forecast
must be that it will be full by the time
this development would happen that takes
into account all the new the pupils that
will come from all the other dwellings
that have been approved so I think
if well no whether they're built or not
it's a forecast so they'll take into
account the the people the pupils that
they think are going to come up but also
from the new dwellings so they they have
forecast that it will be full and that
this development would need to provide
some funding for expansion
um but they haven't said that that
expansion couldn't happen it is a quite
constrained site but they're not
concerned about it being able to be
expanded to provide the small number of
pupils that would come from this
development
thank you counselor
um Busby
I find it strange that
um a document the the neighborhood plan
which basically trumps all other
documents in terms of planning
the housing needs that are specified in
that aren't sufficient for a developer
to take forward and say well this is
what you the village have said
you need this is what you the village
are basing your neighborhood plan on and
this is you the village and what
determine how many houses are required
and where they're required
if I was a developer I'd find it very
strange that I couldn't use the same
information and say I've done my
survey I mean if they'd done a survey
and they'd come up with totally the
opposite information
for the neighborhood plan
would you throw the neighborhood plan
out and say it's not worth the paper
it's written on I mean I can't see how
you can not follow it right
so the survey found a need people said
that they did need some more family
houses and they needed affordable homes
but equally the neighborhood plan
Planned for those homes so it allocated
homes within its neighborhood plan to to
provide for that need so this this
development would provide over the need
that the neighborhood planners found and
therefore the developers would need to
find additional need which isn't covered
by the allocations within the local plan
to in order to justify the need for
these dwellings and that's what they
haven't done
thanks chair actually I was just going
to promote or less come through the same
points in the report 3.2 states that the
answer neighborhood plan exists and in
fact it's the most recent more recent in
the nppf
3.3 states that building outside the
built up area boundary will only be
permitted where it can be satisfactorily
demonstrated there's an identified local
need for the proposal and it cannot be
satisfactorily accommodated for within
the buab settlement boundary 3.4 then
points out that the mst2 is allocation
of sites for an additional 60 dwellings
which presumably would satisfy the the
um identified local need so effectively
this does not meet mst1 in any way shape
or form and I think that's reflected in
the office of recommendation so on that
basis I'd like to propose that we go
ahead with the officer recommendation
for refusal
EMS EMS T1 being to my mind quite
conclusive right I'll serve as a second
uh councilor Plum just saying that
I want to see us supporting neighborhood
plans I think is the best thing that's
happened to planning in this area for a
long time
thank you uh did you want to comment um
you didn't have to hand up before
councilor Parker I'll just say actually
councilman pretty much came to the
conclusion I was I was going to get to
so um yeah I support yeah
uh right members is there any new
comments anybody wish to make
no
it's been proposed and seconded that we
followed the officer's recommendation
before refusal has laid out in the
papers in front of you all those in
favor please show
those against
nope
abstentions
you know we'd like to well that is
Carrie it's very very much
so I've got to the last one
yep
um members we have got to leave here
Barbara till three now I'm sorry
forget what I was talked about we'll go
on now to the last one it's all changed
again
uh we're on little s which is Bank Sealy
and we heard new officer that's on page
113.
foreign
just introduce yourself because I can't
find your name quickly enough
that's it
vote up
okay
so the application is for a single story
rear and a single story side extension
to Mana wood Farm
the application site is located in a
small cluster of dwellings
um
with the highway stuck yard green
running to the west of the property it
continues further south where it reaches
a dead end followed North you it reaches
monk Sealy
bit of contacts are in a very rural
setting you've got monks e-lead directly
to the north with Brent Ely and
Charlesworth also to the north
so it's in a cluster of roughly five
dwellings
um situated on a modest plot set back
from the highway of stackyard green
site constraints they're two grade two
listed buildings to the South
um stackwood Cottage is
thatched property similar to Mana wood
house
there are no other constraints on the
site
this gives an indication of the site
layout so you've got the
original dwelling here
with an existing 20th century
rear and side extension
so this is the rear elevation showing
the thatched
element here with the existing rear
extension
so
this
element is a thatched roof while this
has a tile roof both render
the
you can see from the side elevation that
it's also part brick work on this
elevation
this shows the front elevation and the
side elevation
this North elevation the batch work
continues over the main entrance way
which the entrance doors on the side of
the property
the existing floor plan you can see here
this is the main core of the dwelling
it's got a rectangular historic core
shown by the
one room
width of the property this is the
existing
20th century
extension
due to the historic core the Heritage
team considered the dwelling to be a
non-designated Heritage asset
so it doesn't have
it doesn't have enough significance to
Warrant National designation but it has
some historic interest
so the proposal is for a single story
rear and a single story side extension
so this illustrates the
rear extension which protrudes 1.2
meters from the rear and has a width of
approximately
three point
3.6 meters so it will provide additional
space in the Garden Room
The Proposal also includes a side
extension
which
extends three meters from the side
elevation and two meters from the rear
with a total width of 5.2 meters
the side extension also includes a small
porch
the side extension will create a
ground floor shower room and a utility
room
so this shows the proposed side
extension it will be
Timber Webber board cladding for the
walls and plane tiles for the roof
has a ridge height and Eaves height
lower than the main dwelling from this
elevation
this shows the proposal from the front
elevation as you can see you will see
the
pitch of the side extension
from the rear this is
another angle of the side extension
where you can see the porch
and also illustrates the rear extension
which
will be glazing panels for the walls and
slate for the roof
here you can see the eaves and the ridge
are in line with the existing rear
extension
[Applause]
from the other side elevation you can
see the existing 20th century lean to
extension with both proposed extensions
off the rear
just for some more contacts so the side
extension will come off this part of the
existing dwelling
and
from here you can see the rear extension
will be located in front of the single
door and the windows on the rear
so the Heritage team have identified a
medium level of less than substantial
harm to the non-designated Heritage
asset
they consider it to result in an overly
complicated and disjointed Arrangement
that would detract from the simple form
and relative status of the historic core
of the building
the mppf requires us to take a balanced
judgment regarding the scale of the harm
and the significance of the Heritage
asset
on this basis the recommendations for
refusal based on the Heritage harm
and also on the design of the
extensions which are considered to be
out of character with the host dwelling
The Proposal was contemporary and
designer materials and fails to be of an
appropriate scale and form
thank you
thank you very much
but with no
um Parish Council
or objector or supporter we have John
Oakley from Ali oh well because it's not
a tea uh
who's the applicant or agent
I'm going to put glasses on it
good afternoon
my name is John Ollie I live at
Meadowood farm and my wife and I
purchased it three years ago as we fell
in love with the character and its
history
firstly can I say that we love the house
and the location and our aim is to care
for it and maintain our house
we would never do anything that may harm
it or be detrimental to its character
and historic interest
unfortunately at the back of the house
is an ugly 1970s extension that was
added by previous owners
we've invested a lot of time and money
improving and preserving this house
we've replaced a rotten Soul plate we've
removed concrete render from the
exterior and we've replaced it with
traditional lime render lime wash all in
the local style several Windows have now
been repaired or replaced with locally
made Timber frames we are both
interested in local history and the
vernacular style and have spent three
years planning this proposed extension
and made many changes to it to make it
as aesthetically pleasing and
sympathetic to the original timber frame
core as we possibly can
as we hope to live here for the rest of
our lives part of the proposed extension
is to add a downstairs bathroom in the
short term I have an elderly mother and
mother-in-law who needs mainly to move
in with us and will require Care at a
ground level accommodation longer term
this will enable us to live here for the
rest of our lives
I understand that the planning officer
would like to remove the exist the
existing inappropriate 1970s extension
however we can't afford to
and indeed we don't wish to demolish
this useful space we therefore propose
to alter the 70s extension by improving
it and not touching the original Timber
framed house at all therefore this will
give a more cohesive organic expansion
to the building
we have taken great care in choosing the
materials with post-extension handmade
Timber wooden frames Timber
weatherboarding and traditional tiles on
the roof and we even proposed to remove
the existing concrete interlocking tiles
in the 20th century extension to replace
it with more traditional slates
I've worked in architecture for the past
20 years and during my research I've
looked at and photographed many grade 2
listed thatched properties in baber some
with numerous extensions and add-ons
to help choose this was the help me
choose which would be most sympathetic
for the Mana wood Farm
I'll show my design to many colleagues
who have all agreed that my proposal
actually works and indeed it has been
passed without any objection by all the
local residents and the parish council
the national planning policy framework
says and this has already been said a
balanced judgment will be required
having regard to the scale of any harm
or loss and the significance of the
Heritage asset this is of course a
personal judgment and I hope that this
committee will now make their own
balanced judgment and allow our plans to
proceed
if not we will be left with an ugly
1970s I saw thank you very much to
improve the future Generations
um right I'll just serve as any
questions I I've just got one for you it
says on the papers here in front of us
um has the application been subject
pre-application advice
did you seek pre-application advice did
you go and talk to officers and planners
I didn't think it would be necessary to
be honest
no okay
thank you members
cancer Jameson
um
sorry
um yeah Heritage seem to be
um concerned that you're
where is it going
um concentration of different
architectural forms in the in a small
area
is there and I mean what's the reason
you've gone for the wood boarding rather
than fitting you didn't character with
the other buildings in the area and uh
to please my wife
so it's aesthetically it is an
attractive building that will fit in
very much in baber
thank you yes it's very important to
please the wife
um
councilor Parker
it's really so you're An Architect by
trade I'm not an architect I work with
an architecture practice I'm an
architectural
technicians actually yeah architectural
technician right and and is your would
you say your specialism is in Heritage
um
right okay but
um so uh yeah okay that answers the
question thank you thank you uh Council
on the call my question to Mr Ali was
simply that that you've chosen the
weatherboarding to fit in with the baber
Heritage question I suppose I have to
ask is does it fit in with the rest of
the building as it currently is in terms
of render
as much as anything else would I mean I
don't intend to thatch it but
fortunately not quite what I meant but I
would take my point about the surfacing
it's a different surface uh to the walls
than the walls are lime render but
except in the 1970s one which is a
concrete render which we will take off
uh any other questions members
no
thank you very much
is not
uh here I haven't heard from him
um so it's now over to you members
uh councilor Osborne yeah thank you Mr
could I just ask the officer just to
show the uh if she has a picture of the
garage that has been erected there and
obviously the front of that of that
Cottage it has she a picture of that or
a helpfully looked at it
photo on the slides of the garage can
you show anything yeah
yeah let's go back
so the image on the top right shows
the front elevation
it's quite close to the highway and
there's a hedge hence the
closeness of the photo
[Music]
do we have elevations from from both the
roadsides I mean those would obviously
be the ones that are going to have the
greatest visual impact
we have
you might the highway just runs to the
left of the bottom image
um so you will see parts of the dwelling
from that side
so the road runs along here with some
inters hedging so you can see
primarily the
first floor of the dwelling yeah
and then
you want to go back on the floor plan
this one or
I'm visualizing that as showing from the
road to the South you're seeing the
front elevation the extensions to the
side and the rear would remain to the
side and the rear am I correct
from that
Southern aspect
yeah so all this is remaining it's just
the areas in Gray are the proposed
extensions and then from the western
side the left-hand side
you're going to be seeing in the end
elevation of the traditional thatched
part of the house with all the 70s and
the subsequent extensions also to the
rear
is that right
that left-hand side the West
that's it you will basically all your
extension work 70s and the stuff that's
being applied for now is still going to
be more or less to the rear and not in
your immediately in your face yeah
that's what I was wanting to establish
it was the relationship to the rest of
the landscape yes
can can you just show again those
extensions
um that uh on the that are already there
and will remain and the new ones coming
onto it
because I believe in your your
introduction you said there was quite a
few of them that sounded like a mess
okay so the existing
20th century extension is off the rear
this part here and then it continues to
the side so this is this part you can
see is this side here so extends further
side so it's kind of a wrap around
extension
so then the proposed two extensions will
come from the existing extension so
there's going to be another extent sorry
another extension put on from off the
can you show that one now yeah
um yeah
so from the rear this is this is the
existing
so it's coming from this side and then
off the rear
thank you so my point is that this is
largely concealed from the roadway in
fact the only view that you will get of
that like that and the ones that shown
in both those photographs are from
within the site and by the neighbors
they're not going to be seen
um at large as it were and I think that
might be significant
any other comments members
councilor Parker
yes yeah I I want to know a little bit
about non-designated Heritage assets um
I I don't I don't fully understand in
this example who who says this is a
non-designation is it the local
Authority is it the English Heritage
um Thomas is still here so uh we'll get
some answers from him thanks Cher um yes
so it was identified by me and the
Heritage team as part of the planning
application so when planning
applications come forward
um we can identify buildings at that
stage that we think we're consider to be
a non-resignated Heritage asset
so it's so it's us so it's a local
Authority that's determined that this is
a non-designated Heritage asset so if I
might then share so this is all about
then this is all about interpretation
then surely um subjectivity
uh yes everything we base it on the
guidance provided by historic England on
identifying
um on a undesignated Heritage assets so
they provide some general guidance on
the kind of criteria that might uh lend
a building to to be considered as a
non-designated Heritage asset
okay
uh councilor Barrett thank you um can
you describe what might have been
acceptable to Heritage
um have they applied through and taken
advice
to some extent although we we can't go
too far to designing proposals
um for people in this case I did look at
whether there was any sort of relatively
simple uh changes that could be made to
the design I think they would have it
would have to involve quite a
considerable change to the existing
extension in order to allow for a
greater increase in extension that still
fitted the simple form of the building
beyond that which has been proposed at
the moment
um I think that that the existing
extension makes it more difficult to to
come up with a with a scheme that's
appropriate to the building in this case
plum
so put says put in very simple terms
take the extension down and you might
get your plane permission for a new one
this
so it's quite easy
the op the applicants have to take down
the 70s
extension
and design another one and they may then
get their planes version if they don't
take down the
1970s extension they're not going to get
plenty of the machine recommended by
yourselves
um if they if the applicants and agents
can come up with a design that doesn't
require that that doesn't require the
demolition of the extension but is
appropriate but is appropriate then and
we would consider that but I just
consider that it might be more difficult
to achieve that
um I was a little bit concerned when you
said that um which I understand that you
cannot design the
um the application for the the person
that I would have thought that you could
offer advice and assistance if they're
to come and asked because there was no
pre
um application advice so
um you know I I'm concerned about that
side of it
yep sorry I did have an informal meeting
with the applicant once the application
was to submit submitted to discuss the
design and we did
I did suggest some alternative proposals
but as we've heard
financial reasons that's important yeah
but not a planning consideration
put the existing one back up the picture
of the existing one
so that's what that's what it's going to
look like afterwards from the rear
elevation yeah can we go back to the the
existing one of that
I mean from my point of view it's
it's kind of straightforward which one
looks better
um and I don't think that can possibly
look better than anything
so
I appreciate the part of that will stay
but part of it will be changed I assume
and I would have thought that
what we look like we're looking at will
be a change for the better
and so it might not be perfect but
it's better than what's there now
Council apart
thank you chat right I think they might
require some technical
assistance from our officers if we might
because it occurs to me as far as a
non-designated Heritage assets concerned
paragraph 197 of the mppf is is
prevalent which says that a balanced
judgment will be required having regard
to the scale of any harm or loss and the
significance of the Heritage asset so on
the one hand we have our heritage team
who was saying that um that you know a
medium level of harm would would apply
as a member of the planning committee if
I disagree with that
um using this very same paragraph can I
take the same balancing judgment come to
a different conclusion
I would have thought the answer's got to
be yes
because we you have to have an open View
and balance it up you've heard the
advice from the Heritage you've heard
the other comments in the officers and
it's up to you to answer so yes cancel
The Parkers you can come
I've got further to that the same
paragraphs from the Heritage team I
think
um refer Heritage issues rather refer to
the fact that they regard this as a
medium level of less than substantial
harm I'd say it was actually a much
slighter level given that it does say
within a relatively small area and at
the rear section of the building in
paragraph 9.5 I suspect it's a matter of
um if you like our balance judgment and
my balance judgment I think probably
concurs with councilor Parkers in that
the level of harm is even less than that
stated here and that the area is small
and it runs to the rear of the building
and all of those things put together in
terms of practicalities indicate to me
that we're over estimating the harm and
I think the balance of judgment can be
reduced on that basis the balance of the
uh what's it called the less the
substantial harm it may even be
insignificant second term if that's the
next level down it's certainly at the
lower level of less than substantial
harm thank you councilor Parker
thank you chair and um so absolutely in
accordance with what councilman mccrore
has said and uh with all due respect to
our um to our officers I would like to
recommend that on this occasion we
actually
um go against officers recommendation
and vote to support this application
I have your reasons and I think you've
said some of them and hopefully yeah in
that I'll get a second of once would
give me the roots of course so in in
line with paragraph 197
um of uh of the nppf and we're not
saying office is going to tell me we've
got to have a you know a local plan
policy as well and I'll I'll um I'll see
fine fine okay so in line with 197
um uh having weighed up the application
that directly or indirectly affects
non-designated Heritage assets
um in my balance judgment
um
um I think that the application is uh is
good to go
and the level of harm is less than a
medium level of substantial thank you
where is it the balance judgment the
other Factor was that
um
reasons being small area rear section
and yeah to reduce the level of harm I
think that's the key point and I would
happily second that motion
yeah just before we go into seconding
and voting so to clarify a second though
we haven't got on to the vote yet okay
just before the vote happens
um just to clarify obviously the officer
recommendation differ to that but um
members have concluded that because of
the existing unsightly extension
members can follow it
um it's verbal at the moment as to what
was said by my members
um have concluded that the proposal is
actually am I getting this right an
improvement on the
from some aspects so so we can we can
cite 197 there paragraph 197 and also
under local plan policy cn01 site that
as a design Improvement it's obviously
quite a difference from opinion here but
your opinion is that
that's it you accept cn01 cr01 calls for
improvement does it not yeah yes and yes
the Heritage aspect um cn06 uh which
looks at um Heritage matters you're
you're stating that you see it as an
improvement to the Heritage asset so you
would cite those policies
balanced judgment so members are
disagreeing to the extent that they say
there is no harm it's an improvement
yes this disagreement members are saying
there is no harm there's an improvement
I I just want to make sure I understood
that thank you
Chancellor Busby
agree with all of that unfortunately it
to me it's an improvement from awful
to okay
I still think there is room
for it to be better even to the level of
good or great
um
so it to me it's a step in the right
direction but there could be even a
better solution I don't know whether
they can continue to look at uh ways of
getting a better solution out of it and
then come back
in the future I guess
um Can supposedly I'm inclined to agree
with you uh it's it's a great pity that
there hadn't been any more talking going
on between the Heritage and officers and
the applicant because I I do agree this
this is certainly better than what's
there at the moment but I still think
it's a mess but it's it's the it's the
best of a bad situation I certainly
don't feel that uh it should be refused
and I have to say that
um and so I'm quite pleased to hear that
proposal coming forward
um because there can be work done but I
would hope even at the Slate stage
perhaps
um I don't know what the conditions will
be we'll come to that in a moment and
perhaps the applicant can get together
with the officers and the Heritage
people and see if they can improve it
even at the slip of hour
anyway conditions
thank you chair yeah obviously the
proposal is what it is and if they
choose to change they can do for a
resubmission which can be discussed but
anyway the the conditions for travelers
has got ready thank you um are the
standard time limit one of three years
um development to a called with the
approved plans and documents prior to
works of slab level details of proposed
external roof and wall facing materials
to be used to be agreed
also prior to Works above slab level
detailed section drawings through the
eaves and verges of the proposed
extension at scale 1 to 20 and finally
new rainwater Goods to match existing
they say they sound a lot like the
normal ones and I don't think there's
anything extra special added uh
councilman score then cancel our sport I
was just going to say that those
conditions and particularly the ones
regarding materials could be used to
address the very points you raised Mr
chairman in terms of making it better I
think that's exactly the opportunity to
achieve that well the applicants in the
room and that obviously hopefully
they're listening to that and they will
perhaps take that our concerns on board
counselors
thank you Mr chairman
um you know I absolutely agree with with
councilor Park on councilman crawl that
it can only in my opinion it can only
better that that Cottage it it looks an
absolute Messer in the back what I would
say to the owners is that you never know
what's around the corner if you're doing
a lottery
uh but I obviously I would like to
obviously I would like to see the whole
of that redone them all in fact talking
to the officers and Heritage to get to
get that number it's a it's a very good
Improvement and we've had uh situations
in the past which I've I've set on and
we've agreed to those and I think it's
only improved that that uh that property
think is important to point out that
even with the conditions if we're minded
to approve this it will be for what's in
front of us we may have said all our
comments and views of how we'd like it
improved but uh that would be what
you'll be given permission on but uh I
certainly I don't think people are
unreasonable
um cancel that is yes very quick one
you're new to the area three years but
there is a man called Peter Minter the
Brickman councilor Ayers can you please
address it to me
I couldn't make out or hear what he was
on about a local brick mate um who who
restores a lot of very old buildings
Peter Minter
um you maybe could they could contact
him good bricks
um that that's the uh advert down we'll
now continue
now let's keep serious here
um right members is there any new
factors you want to uh raise right no
and you're satisfied with those
conditions and the uh comments right
it's been proposed and seconded that we
approved this against the officers uh
advice with the follow-on conditions
that you heard read out all those in
favor please show
and that's the first few members one all
day thank you
that is carried
[Music]
date of the site inspection
yeah the date of the site inspection is
next Wednesday